Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues je vous propose qu'on commence
bonjour à vous tous
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour cette table ronde sur
le thème de l'énergie et de l'Union
européenne thème qui nous quitte pas
puisque on a terminé tard hier soir avec
un débat ici sur l'énergie en France
c'est bien sûr toujours un plaisir que
de travailler avec la commission des
affaires européennes donc je salue et
remercie son président Jean-François
Rapin c'est en effet la troisième fois
que nous nous retrouvons sur l'énergie
c'est évidemment légitime au regard de
la structuration de l'énergie en France
et en Europe après nos travaux sur la
taxonomie verte européenne et le paquet
ajustement à l'objectif 55 notre
commission est très engagée la
commission des affaires économiques en
faveur de la décarbonation de l'énergie
à l'échelon national mais aussi à
l'échelon européen je rappelle que
l'Union européenne est face à un double
défi d'ici 2030 réduire de 55% ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
conformément au paquet 55 5 et sortir de
sa dépendance aux hydrocarbures russes
en application du plan ripower
bien consciente de la nécessité mais
aussi de la difficulté de cet exercice
notre commission a fait adopter une
résolution forte que vous devez
connaître sur ce sujet appuyé par les
parlementaires des 27 États membres le
14 mars 2022 dans le cadre de l'apfue
dans ce contexte très délicat je
souhaiterais recueillir l'opinion de nos
intervenants que je salue et que je
remercie évidemment d'être là surtout à
trois points le premier c'est l'énergie
nucléaire la moitié des États membres
dispose d'un parc de deuxième génération
et un quart est engagé dans la
construction de réacteurs de troisième
génération la Belgique est dans une
moindre mesure l'Allemagne aux suspendu
leur trajectoire de sortie du nucléaire
or la taxonomie est défavorable à
l'énergie nucléaire qui est assimilée à
une activité de transition vous me direz
c'est déjà un premier une première
victoire en soi mais une pensée que ce
n'est pas assez comme le gaz d'ailleurs
et non à une activité durable comme les
autres énergies décarbonées par ailleurs
les délais et les conditions posées sont
impraticables pour accompagner la
relance du nucléaire en France sans
compter le contentieux annoncé par
l'Autriche et le Luxembourg j'aimerais
avoir votre point de vue sur ce sujet il
faudrait-il pas corriger le tir pour
mobiliser tous les moyens de
décarbonation au sein de l'Union et
respecter le droit souverain des États
membres de définir leur mixte
énergétique le deuxième point dont je
voudrais parler ce sont les métaux
stratégiques nous le savons nos pales
d'éoliennes nos batteries électriques
nos électrodiseurs d'hydrogène sont de
grands consommateurs de métaux rares et
stratégique or nous ne devons pas
troquer notre dépendance actuelle aux
énergies fossiles par une dépendance
future évidemment aux métaux
stratégiques c'est pourquoi nous
plaidons pour que la taxonomie intègre
le Conseil le concept de mine durable et
que le paquet 5 soit complétée par une
stratégie européenne de sécurisation des
métaux mindurables et approvisionnements
si la Russie fournit 45% du charbon et
du gaz et 25% du pétrole de l'Union elle
est aussi un grand exportateur de métaux
30% de l'aluminium du nickel ou du
cuivre quel est votre appréciation ne
faudrait-il pas réduire cette dépendance
minière pour extraire en Europe mais
aussi développer des substituts et bien
sûr renforcer le recyclage troisième
point que je souhaiterais évoquer c'est
le stockage de l'énergie car les
énergies renouvelables pêchent toujours
par leur intermittence pour y remédier
nous pouvons développer leur stockage
l'hydraulique les batteries électriques
les électrolyseurs d'hydrogène c'est une
possibilité j'allais dire et même une
obligation nous souhaitons donc
consolider les projets d'intérêt
européen commun les pièques qui existent
en matière pour les batteries et
l'hydrogène il est crucial de combler
leur financement hauteur d'un milliard
600 en France de plus il faut garantir
une neutralité
technologique entre tous les modes de
stockage le paquet 55 se focalise sur
l'hydrogène renouvelable en oubliant
peut-être l'hydrogène nucléaire alors
qu'il est au fondement de la stratégie
française pour un hydrogène décarbonate
quel est votre position sur le sujet ne
faut-il pas constituer des chaînes de
valeurs européennes en matière de
stockage pour accompagner les sorts des
énergies renouvelables et préférez une
production locale à des importations
lointaines
je veux je vous remercie de votre
éclairage sur d'avance sur ces questions
qui nous semblent cruciales en
réfléchissant peut-être à ce qu'on
appellerait un peu rapidement les
impensés du Green Deal que sont
l'énergie nucléaire les métaux
stratégiques et le stockage de l'énergie
je pense que nous pouvons progresser
dans le sens d'une économie européenne
moins émissive et moins dépendantes les
deux étant à égalité dans je pense les
priorités actuelles de l'Union
européenne en tout cas devant l'être la
transition et la souveraineté doivent à
notre avis agir de concert voilà je
laisse la parole au président après
merci Madame Présidente chers Sophie
messieurs les directeurs mesdames mes
chers collègues la crise de l'énergie
n'a pas encore commencé qui trait la
chronique des échos de mardi dernier
ce titre illustre jusque là de la
flambée des prix des énergies à laquelle
l'Europe doit faire face et qui je le
rappelle a débuté dès la fin de l'été
2021 donc avant l'agression russe en
Ukraine ce profil un choc d'activité
majeur et durable pour l'économie
européenne dans son ensemble avec un
risque de désindustrialisation il est
évident qu'il n'y aura pas de retour au
niveau de prix d'avant la crise que nous
traversons actuellement ce moment
critique mais brutalement au jour la
dépendance de l'Union européenne elle
est garde des énergies fossiles ça
dépendances envers un petit nombre de
fournisseurs et aussi ces divisions
profondes en matière de politique
énergétique pourtant les questions
d'énergie ont joué un rôle déterminant
dans sa naissance puisque la première
institution commune des 6 pays
fondateurs de l'Union européenne fut en
1951 la Communauté européenne du charbon
et de l'acier
suivi de la Communauté européenne de
l'énergie atomique les pères fondateurs
de l'Europe moderne avaient bien saisi
le caractère stratégique du sujet après
avoir largement libéralisé les marchés
de l'énergie l'Union européenne se
trouve aujourd'hui face à un double
enjeu il s'agit à la fois d'assurer sa
souveraineté énergétique et d'accélérer
la transition énergétique
ce double objectif n'est pas simple à
atteindre ainsi le charbon
contribue-t-il à la sécurité des
approvisionnements mais nuit à la
performance environnementale les
énergies renouvelables aideraient à
réaliser cette dernière même si elle se
heurte à la problématique du stockage de
l'électricité mais elle coûte encore
trop cher ou se déploie au prix de
nouvelles dépendances avec des
fournisseurs le gaz est finalement
apparu comme le combustible de choix des
investisseurs dans le marché libéralisé
de l'électricité mais son utilisation a
augmenté les importations et l'énergie
nucléaire dont certains discutent le
bilan environnemental malgré son
caractère décarboné cristallise encore
des oppositions fortes en Europe
un des enjeux clés dans cette équation
complexe et le prix de l'énergie le
niveau actuel de ce prix
oblige l'Union à résoudre cette
quadrature du cercle et ramène la
question énergétique au centre du projet
européen à la fois dans sa dimension
économique et dans sa dimension
géopolitique
les réunions du Conseil européen et du
Conseil ainsi que les réunions
informelles consacrées à l'énergie se
succèdent ces derniers mois un rythme
soutenu la Commission a ainsi été
invitée par les États membres à plancher
et doit poursuivre sa réflexion sur des
mécanismes de réduction des prix des
énergies à court et moyen terme elle
devrait présenter une nouvelle
proposition législative sur le
plafonnement des prix du gaz tout
prochainement
c'est ce contexte sensible qui a conduit
les commissions des affaires européennes
et à faire économiques et organiser
cette table ronde sur les enjeux
stratégiques de l'énergie pour l'Union
européenne d'ailleurs suivant un débat
au titre de l'article 50-1 hier soir en
séance je remercie les intervenants qui
ont bien voulu se rendre disponible pour
y participer
et je vais d'abord laisser la parole à
Monsieur
pèlerin Carlin monsieur le directeur qui
a rejoint l'Institut économique pour le
climat en tant que directeur du
programme Europe selon vous comment la
crise de l'énergie met-elle à l'épreuve
l'Union européenne et quelles sont les
causes de la crise et les voies de
sortie à court et moyen terme je sais
aussi que vous êtes contraint en horaire
donc la parole est à vous
merci beaucoup
donc je m'appelle Thomas Pellerin Carlin
je suis effectivement directeur du
programme Europe de l'Institut de
l'économie pour le climat et donc notre
spécialité c'est vraiment de travailler
sur les enjeux d'économie
d'investissement et de finances pour
affronter et surmonter ce défi
macroéconomique qui est le dérèglement
climatique à la fois dans la
transformation de notre économie pour
réduire les risques climatiques au 21e
siècle mais aussi dans l'adaptation à ce
dérèglement climatique qui est
carrément inévitable
pour j'aimerais en fait dresser un peu
le contexte historique voir quels ont
été les crises passées
quelle est la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui et quelles peuvent être les
pistes de sortie de crise pour le futur
d'abord il faut se rappeler qu'on ne vit
pas la première crise des énergies
fossiles
vous voyez sur cette petite frise
chronologique
les différentes crises des énergies
fossiles crises de prix et de quantité
et parfois seulement crise de prix donc
on n'est pas du tout dans la première
la première crise des énergies fossiles
qui a marqué la France et l'ouest de
l'Union européenne évidemment le premier
choc pétrolier qui faisait suite à la
guerre du Kippour
juste pour rappeler la situation et vous
pouvez faire le parallèle historique qui
me semble assez évident vous avez une
petite nation démocratique Israël qui se
fait attaquer par surprise par ses
voisins en tout cas deux en particulier
de ces de ses voisins qui au début crée
la surprise réussisse à gagner
militairement et après il y a une
réaction de ce petit État démocratique
ces acteurs là ensuite les envahisseurs
sont dans une situation difficile et
utilise l'arme de l'énergie fossile à
l'époque c'est le pétrole pour
sanctionner pas simplement ce petit état
mais aussi ses alliés
vous voyez le parallèle évidemment avec
la situation absolument
donc premier choc pétrolier 73 qui
provoque sur l'économie française pas
une inflation et l'entrée dans un
nouveau monde et la sortie de souvent ce
qu'on a appelé les 30 glorieuses
pétroliers de 79 et dans les années 2000
on a eu les premières crisesières qui
sont des crises provoquées par des
désaccords pour le dire comme ça entre
la Russie l'Ukraine dès 2006 l'Ukraine
fait une première révolution essaye de
devenir une nation démocratique
indépendante de la cryptocratie de
l'oligarchie russe l'oligarchie de
l'admire Poutine pour être plus précis
et la réussite va devenir Poutine
utilise l'arme gazière pour essayer de
faire plier l'Ukraine dès 2006
la leçon qui est donc évidemment depuis
2000 21 il faut quand même le dire voilà
on est rentré dans cette grande crise
énergétique européenne donc je voulais
vraiment placer la situation dans
laquelle on vit dans cette histoire
longue
cette histoire longue qui nous rappelle
le coût économique et géopolitique de
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
qui est évident aujourd'hui mais qui est
évident en fait depuis un demi siècle en
réalité
si on dézoom et qu'on regarde la
situation au niveau mondial la grande
spécificité énergétique du continent
européen
c'est que c'est un continent européen
qui est pauvre en énergie fossile
et le paradoxe historique c'est que nous
Européens pendant des décennies nous
avons construit notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles nous avons construit
nos dépendances à des sources d'énergie
que nous ne possédons pas
au début du 20e siècle c'était fait
parce qu'en fait les Européens
possédaient ces sources-là parce que les
pays européens non même le pétrole parce
que les Européens étaient les empires
et donc du coup
en toute conséquence la période de
décolonisation et de fin des empires
européens aurait dû nous amener à nous
poser la question de nos choix
énergétiques puisque désormais nous ne
contrôlions plus directement la
production de pétrole en particulier à
l'époque
alors regardons la situation
présente là ce que vous avez c'est le
mix énergétique français
je le présente en énergie finale
il est peu souvent présenté comme ça et
ça me semble dommage l'énergie finale
c'est l'énergie durant ces la
statistique qui nous permet de mieux
mesurer l'énergie réellement utile pour
les activités humaines
donc là par exemple ce que vous avez sur
le nucléaire vous voyez que le nucléaire
n'est que à 17% de l'énergie finalement
en France c'est l'énergie que le
nucléaire produit et qui est
effectivement utile donc c'est
l'électricité c'est pas les nuages de
vapeur d'eau qui sont au-dessus des
centrales qui ne sont pas dans ces
statistiques là mais qui sont étant
passant pour être utilisés un slovaque
l'utilise pour chauffer des villes donc
c'est
la leçon à tirer de ce graphique là
c'est que la France est un pays
extrêmement dépendant
du pétrole et du gaz
la première source d'énergie consommée
en France en 2019 c'est le pétrole c'est
quasiment la moitié de l'énergie
consommée en France qui vient du pétrole
la deuxième c'est le gaz possible la
troisième en 2019 c'était le nucléaire
dès 2020 ce sont les énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire du coup
aujourd'hui n'est plus que la quatrième
source d'énergie consommée en France
elle est évidemment extrêmement
importante pour secteur de l'électricité
mais il faut toujours remettre cela dans
le contexte plus général de l'énergie et
qu'on regarde au sein des énergies
renouvelables vous voyez en fait que la
majorité des énergies renouvelables
consommées en France c'est de la
biomasse
qui n'a aucun problème en termes
d'intermittence
et des autres énergies renouvelables qui
sont en train d'être développés
notamment l'éolien et le solaire mais
qui pour l'instant représente une toute
petite part de la consommation
énergétique française puisque la
République française a choisi de ne pas
vraiment soutenir les énergies
renouvelables non
on a 27 États dans l'Union européenne
ils ont tous un objectif de déploiement
des énergies renouvelables fixées par le
droit européen
sur les 27 États membres de l'Union
européenne il y en a 26 qui l'ont
atteint
il y en a un qui vient pas atteint c'est
la France
donc en termes de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables la France fait
moins bien et vraiment à la fin des 27
la France a moins fait d'efforts que la
Pologne
ce qui est d'autant plus paradoxal que
la France est un pays qui est
extrêmement riche
en énergie renouvelable on a la chance
d'avoir des montagnes et du bois c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait la majorité des
énergies renouvelables qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui on a aussi la chance d'avoir
énormément de vent et des régimes de
vente très différents ce qui permet de
gérer l'enjeu de variabilité la
production éolienne et on est aussi un
pays qui est extrêmement riche en soleil
et le soleil on peut utiliser pour faire
de l'électricité mais aussi pour faire
de la chaleur moi ma technologie
préférée c'est le solaire thermique qui
permet de chauffer de l'eau pour des
usages résidentiels mais aussi
industriels et la France a moins
développé le solaire thermique que
l'Autriche par exemple
alors que la France est un pays qui est
globalement plus ensoleillé que que
l'Autriche
alors petit tour d'horizon de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes sur
le pétrole les prix sont absolument
normaux les prix sont même bas
quand vous regardez les prix du pétrole
au niveau mondial les prix du pétrole
aujourd'hui sont plus bas qu'ils ne
l'était durant toute l'année 2012 toutes
les années 2013 et le début de l'année
2014 et je ne promets pas même pas en
compte l'inflation
donc les prix sont absolument normaux ce
qui est anormal au regard de l'histoire
c'est la politique française de
subventions de consommation de l'essence
par la réduction des taxes donc la
subvention aux énergies fossile y
compris dans un contexte où les prix du
pétrole sont encore une fois
historiquement complètement
normaux sur l'enjeu de la quantité de
pétrole il n'y a pas de risque de
pénurie au niveau structurel et il y a
évidemment l'enjeu de des grèves que
qui est au coeur de l'actualité en ce
moment
sur le gaz la situation est très
différente
sur le gaz on a des prix qui sont
historiquement élevés et c'est un
euphémisme puisque les prix aujourd'hui
sont environ 1000% plus cher
que les prix qu'on considéré comme
normaux dans la décennie 2017
ces prix-là devrait rester très élevés
dans le très élevé dans la durée
probablement pendant 5 ans
donc je pense que
la mandature actuelle de l'Assemblée
nationale et du président de la
République va être marqué par des prix
du gaz qui vous restez élevés pendant
toute la mandature probablement jusqu'en
les prix peuvent baisser mais ils
resteront à des niveaux extrêmement
élevés et c'est peut-être même en
réalité l'entrée dans une nouvelle ère
un peu comme après le premier choc
pétrolienne 1973 on est passé d'un
pétrole qui ne coûtait rien du tout un
pétrole qui avait un prix important on
est peut-être déjà passé dans un monde
où on passe d'un gaz vraiment pas cher à
un gaz qui est structurellement
extrêmement cher parce que nous repérant
somme devenu dépendants du gaz naturel
et
le gaz naturel qui est pour des raisons
physiques et des raisons économiques et
structurellement deux fois trois fois
quatre fois plus cher que le gaz qu'on a
porté de la Russie par gazoduc dans la
décennie précédente pour le dire
autrement il faudra qu'on vit avec des
prix japonais du gaz
c'est une transformation importante pour
notre industrie en particulier il faut
que notre industrie réussisse à trouver
un modèle économique viable
en étant dans un monde où les prix
repère du gaz seront globalement au même
niveau que les prix japonais ce qui
n'était pas du tout le cas pendant 40
ans
sur le gaz il y a un risque de pénurie à
partir de février mars de 2023 et
surtout courant 2024
l'hiver qui s'annonce sera compliqué
l'hiver d'après sera encore plus dur
puisqu'il faudra très probablement
refaire des stocks de gaz sans gaz russe
et donc du coup là aussi on est sur une
crise dans la durée du coup je me
permets vraiment d'insister sur ce point
la crise qu'on vit aujourd'hui sur le
gaz c'est peut-être même pas une crise
au sens où c'est pas un problème aigu
qui dure trois ans et après on retourne
à la normale c'est peut-être et je pense
c'est même très probablement l'entrée
dans un nouveau monde de gaz qui coûte
structurellement extrêmement cher pour
des décennies
juste pour vous interrompre vous dites
pénurie dès février 2023 pourtant le
gouvernement nous dit aucun aucun souci
pas de pénurie n'ayez pas peur puisque
nos stocks sont à plus de 110% je crois
de réserve alors les stocks que est-ce
que c'est une pénurie
d'approvisionnement et auquel cas mais
où est-ce que c'est une pénurie chez les
industriels et les particuliers alors
les stocks de gaz sont pas dimensionnés
pour qu'on puisse passer tout l'hiver
uniquement avec les stocks
les stocks de gaz en Europe globalement
là on doit avoir 80 milliards de mètres
cubes stockés au niveau européen donc y
compris les stocks français 80 milliards
de mètres cubes je parle sous le
contrôle de Marc-Antoine mais on sait ce
qu'on consomme en hiver en deux mois
globalement
donc nos stocks de gaz ils sont faits
pour
comment dire stocker du gaz durant
durant l'été il utilise un peu durant
l'hiver alors qu'on continue à avoir des
approvisionnements en hiver on n'est pas
au stade des questions
de stockage manuels sont remplies voilà
c'est quand le gouvernement dit nos
stocks sont plein c'est nos capacités de
stockage qui sont remplies mais nos
capacités de stockage ne couvrent pas
les besoins absolument
pour poursuit plus rapidement du coup
cette sur l'électricité on a des prix
qui sont anormalement élevés
avant toi à cause de la hausse des prix
du gaz puisque les prix de l'électricité
sont déterminés par les prix du gaz dès
qu'on a besoin de gaz pour produire de
l'électricité donc c'est pas tout le
temps
là pour le coup on est dans cette
situation où il y a besoin du gaz pour
produire l'électricité parce que la
demande d'électricité reste très élevée
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu encore de
mobilisation nationale ou européenne
pour baisser les prix de l'électricité
comme ce qu'on fait les Japonais en 2011
après Fukushima où ils ont réussi à
baisser de 15% immédiatement pas de
promettre de le faire pour plus tard
et on a évidemment le problème de la
production nucléaire en France que
j'imagine est connu donc là dessus les
risques de pénurie sont surtout en
décembre 2022 puisque on a l'espoir que
EDF réussisse à relancer certains
réacteurs nucléaires à partir de janvier
février mais évidemment c'est une c'est
une inconnue là aussi sur les prix de
l'électricité
pour autant qu'on puisse prédire
l'avenir là aussi on a on est parti
probablement pour deux trois quatre ans
de prix de prix très élevés parce que la
faible production nucléaire française va
rester faible pendant deux trois quatre
ans au minimum et parce qu'on a des prix
du gaz qui sont extrêmement élevés
alors les causes profondes je vais quand
même dire un mot là dessus il y a eu un
choix de sous-investissement dans
l'efficacité énergétique et dans les
énergies renouvelables on paye
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on paye le coût
économique de la procrastination dans
les investissements dans les énergies
propres
pas assez de rénovation en France je
vous cite juste un chiffre si la France
avait mis en œuvre le plan de rénovation
des bâtiments adoptés en 2008 lors du
Grenelle de l'environnement dont je vous
parle d'un plan tout à fait raisonnable
approuvé par Nicolas Sarkozy
si ce plan-là avait vraiment été mis en
oeuvre la France serait indépendante du
gaz russe
évidemment ça n'a pas été fait on est
toujours dépendant du gaz russe et du
gaz plus généralement
là aussi trop peu de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables production très
insuffisante évidemment sur le secteur
électrique si on avait installé par
exemple plus d'éolien ou de solaire on
aurait des prix électricité plus bas
on évidemment sur la question de la
chaleur si on avait installé plus de
soleil thermique en particulier on
consommerait moins de gaz aujourd'hui
pour finir les leçons qu'on peut tirer
de cette septième ou huitième crise des
énergies fossiles mais qui est
particulièrement grave et
particulièrement aigus pour moi la
première leçon c'est vraiment que nous
ne pouvons pas nous payer le luxe de
rester dépendant des énergies fossiles
les journalistes me posent souvent la
question du coût de la transition et moi
je le réponds par le coût de la non
transition je parle même pas du climat
juste si regarde d'un point de vue
économique ça ne fait pas sens pour le
continent européen qui est pauvre en
énergie fossile de continuer de rester
dans un système où le continent et notre
nation dépend d'apportation d'énergie
fossile de l'étranger ça nous coûte
extrêmement cher dès qu'on a un problème
sur les énergies fossiles on a un choc
flacioniste comme on l'a eu en 73 comme
on l'a eu au 79 comme on l'a aujourd'hui
ça crée des dépenses géopolitiques
majeures aujourd'hui évidemment c'est la
Russie de l'annuaire Poutine qui est
centrale dans notre pensée mais quid des
États-Unis lorsque ils éliront à un
président qui nous sera hostile ça peut
être Donald Trump au run de 110 en 2024
comme ça peut être quelqu'un d'autre
plus tard donc là aussi c'est une
dépendance géopolitique extrêmement
importante qui
nous coûte extrêmement cher je
politiquement du Mondial évidemment
l'impact climatique puisque quand on
choisit de rester dans les énergies
fossiles on
climatique qui nous coûte cher et on l'a
vu cet été on a et c'est une première
estimation qui est raffinée probablement
50 000 Européens qui sont morts cet été
des vagues de chaleur
on a les feux de forêts qui coûtent cher
y compris au dépenses publiques et on a
évidemment la sécheresse qui crée des
disruptions importantes sur les chaînes
de valeur industrielles sur les chaînes
de valeur agricoles et tout ça c'est de
l'argent privé comme public qu'il faudra
malheureusement bien trouver la crise
actuelle elle peut tout à fait durer 5
ans voire plus le Premier ministre belge
d'Alexander de Crau a dit qu'il fallait
se préparer à 5 à 10 hivers difficiles
ça me semble tout à fait raisonnable et
du coup il faut à mon avis que votre
réponse politique à vous il est la
nation part de ce diagnostic nous sommes
sur une crise de moyen terme qui
s'inscrit dans une histoire de long
terme de crise d'énergie fossile il faut
donc apporter une réponse évidemment une
partie de la réponse c'est l'urgence
sociale mais il faut aussi apporter une
réponse de moyen terme
et un moyen terme sur ces décennies là
on a un besoin massif d'investissement
dans la sobriété énergétique la sobriété
énergétique c'est aussi des
investissements notamment des
collectivités locales il faut que les
collectivités locales et les moyens
d'investir pour par exemple déployer les
systèmes de transport public de piste
cyclables aménagé etc besoin
d'investissement dans l'efficacité
énergétique la rénovation des bâtiments
c'est un élément essentiel pour qu'on
puisse se sortir de la crise et les
énergies renouvelables toutes les
énergies renouvelables à mon avis sans
aucune exception puisqu'on n'a pas le
luxe on peut pas se payer le luxe de
mettre de côté une source d'énergie des
carbonées
pour faire tout ça il faut planifier il
faut planifier ses investissements là
vous et les nations vous avez un devoir
de planifier ces investissements là au
niveau de l'État mais notamment au Sénat
de le faire en coopération avec les
collectivités territoriales puisqu'il
faut du coup que cette planification
nationale s'articule avec le niveau
européen avec peut-être à venir un plan
d'investissement européen pour sortir de
la crise des énergies fossiles avec le
niveau national avec les collectivités
locales et bien sûr évidemment avec les
entreprises puisque
il nous faut trouver une manière
d'alimenter en énergie notre industrie
ça peut plus être le gaz fossile ça
coûte trop cher il faut donc trouver
d'autres solutions pour sortir des
énergies fossiles puisqu'on ne sortira
de cette crise qu'en sortant des
énergies fossiles
merci beaucoup
je vais donner maintenant la parole à
Monsieur Marc-Antoine el mazega
directeur du Centre énergie climat de
l'Institut français des relations
internationales et merci d'aborder la
dimension internationale les enjeux
géopolitiques de la crise de l'énergie
même si on les a déflorés dans
l'intervention précédente je vous
demande d'essayer de tenir les 10
minutes si vous pouvez que les autres
interlocuteurs et le temps et surtout
que je sens qu'il va y avoir des
questions
merci beaucoup et pour compléter ce
premier cette première analyse peut-être
vous en réalité c'est de renforcer ce
que dit Thomas pour vous dire que mon
sentiment
mon analyse c'est que Poutine a déclaré
la guerre à l'Europe a déclaré la guerre
à l'Union européenne à l'OTAN et pas
ceux depuis le 24 février mais en
réalité depuis bien avant probablement
2014 peut-être même encore avant et les
seuls qui finalement l'avaient vu de
façon assez claire en Europe c'est les
pays baltes c'est la Pologne
la deuxième chose c'est qu'évidemment
l'arme gaziaire est extraordinairement
efficace pour les raisons qui évoquées
Thomas c'est à dire que nous sommes nous
avons même renforcé dans un certain
nombre de pays en Europe la dépendance
au gaz en général et au gaz russe en
particulier
évidemment parce que cinq années de prix
bas 2015-2020 nous ont totalement
anesthésiés on a quand même eu une
période extraordinaire de prix
extraordinairement bas sur l'électricité
sur le gaz sur le charbon sur le pétrole
donc ça nous a permis de nous doter de
façon consensuelle d'objectif
extraordinairement ambitieux de
décarbonation puisque il n'y avait pas
de sujets de sécurité
d'approvisionnements tout cela avait
l'air assez facile finalement
heureusement tant mieux mais d'une autre
façon ça nous a anesthésié et ça nous a
aussi empêché de prendre pleinement la
mesure du sous-investissement généralisé
qui a eu lieu alors Thomas évoqué le
sous-investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables et l'efficacité
énergétique dont on paie le prix très
fort aujourd'hui mais
sous-investissement aussi dans le gaz
sous-investissement aussi dans la mine
et on va en reparler dans un instant
sous-investissement dans les
infrastructures en général
électrique les réseaux etc donc on sort
en réalité
on est dans la dans le tambour de la
machine à laver qui tourne à 600 tours
pour pouvoir similtour et on est
effectivement pas prêt d'en sortir donc
il faut voir un petit peu aussi tout
tout ses conséquences là
on sort aussi je crois d'un d'une
situation on s'était payé le luxe
d'avoir des débats idéologiques que vous
ayez référence madame prima sur
est-ce que le nucléaire finalement c'est
bien ou pas est-ce que les éoliennes à
terre c'est bien ou pas est-ce que les
parcs en mer
gâche la vue voilà non mais on en était
là dans toute l'Europe et on en est
encore là malheureusement et en fait je
suis très choqué de voir que c'est un
peu comme si vous étiez un soldat
ukrainien au front les Russes avancent
et vous vous demandez s'il vaut mieux
prendre le fusil autrichien le couteau
fourni par les Allemands le casque
j'allais dire fourni par je ne sais qui
non mais en fait on en est pas là en
réalité donc pour vous traduire cela
autrement nous sommes en situation de
guerre et nous sommes nous-mêmes en
posture de drôles de guerre et quand je
dis ça ça concerne aussi toutes les
mesures d'efficacité d'économie
d'énergie c'est à dire il faut quand
même voir les choses en face Thomas le
rappeler on écoute au début des crises
et les choses ne vont qu'empirer et donc
notre principal instrument pour faire
face là dans l'immédiat c'est les
économies mais pour faire des économies
il faut les faire de façon
ultra efficace et ultra intelligente
donc réduire de 35 pour tout le monde
les le prix de l'essence à la pompe
c'est absolument
inefficace
d'augmenter le prix de l'électricité du
gaz que de 4% cette année et de 15% et
prochaine c'est hyper inefficace par
contre
avoir une vraie politique de
redistribution pour les plus vulnérables
dont le nombre de fé qu'augmenter ça
c'est important ça c'est hyper important
mais où est le signal prix où est le
signal prix et où est la crédibilité de
la mobilisation
c'est un immense défi et encore une fois
on n'a pas 36 instruments la crise va
être terrible il faut dégager des
volumes de gaz pour l'industrie c'est un
impératif et ça ne se fera pas comme ça
effectivement
me semble-t-il donc là il y a quand même
un sujet très très grave sur lequel
j'aimerais vous vous alerter alors un
autre point peut-être sur
ce qui se passe ma spécialité c'est un
peu quand même de regarder ce qui se
passe dans le reste du monde là il faut
bien avoir conscience que l'Europe après
l'Ukraine évidemment et l'immense
perdante tout ce qui se passe le choc
est absolument dévastateur donc en fait
pour le dire autrement c'est un peu
comme si 500 missiles russes c'était
abattu pour détruire 10% de notre
industrie d'ergot intensive et chaque
mois qui passe on rajoute un point de
pourcentage de destruction donc c'est
absolument colossal mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on soit en situation de
mobilisation et la conséquence de cela
évidemment c'est qu'il va falloir éviter
qu'on ait une fermeture définitive d'un
certain nombre d'industries mais il faut
aussi avoir confiance que une partie de
certains de ce capital installé va en
réalité fermée définitivement la
production d'ammoniac en Europe je la
vois jamais repartir donc voilà ça ça
des conséquences quand même très
sérieuses
sur le sur finalement que ce qu'on peut
faire et il me reste encore je crois
quelques minutes alors sur ce qu'on peut
faire la première chose évidemment vous
évoquez le l'électricité nucléaire mais
alors d'abord c'est pas ça qui va nous
sortir de la crise au contraire c'est ce
qui ne malheureusement nous a un petit
peu renforcé dans notre crise ça c'est
pas Poutine qui a créé les problèmes sur
le parc français donc il faut encore il
faut quand même bien avoir ça exprimer
cela dit c'est pas une solution là pour
les trois quatre prochaines années c'est
vraiment une solution évidemment pour le
long terme mais il est absolument
évident que nos amis Autrichiens
luxembourgeois et autres et bien en
réalité contribue à s’aborder notre
effort général pour nous sortir de nos
crises et surtout pour atteindre les
objectifs 2030 et 2050 donc là il y a
quand même un moment il va falloir se
dire des choses très clairement
la deuxième le deuxième élément c'est
que en réalité c'est pas juste une crise
nucléaire c'est une crise structurelle
tout le parc installé de génération en
France va devoir être remplacé d'ici
2050 enfin c'est quand même immense
voilà on le sait et c'est en réalité le
cas dans la plupart des pays européens
on va falloir qu'on ait des nouvelles
capacités flexibles qui devront être
thermiques parce qu'on n'a pas 36 autres
solutions on va pouvoir mettre des
batteries pour le court terme il faudra
en mettre beaucoup plus les États-Unis
sont beaucoup plus avancés que nous là
dedans dans ce domaine-là les Allemands
aussi d'ailleurs en Europe mais il va
falloir du stockage de long terme et ça
bien sûr on pourra parler d'hydrogène
quel que soit la couleur mais cela dit
ça ne suffira pas donc il va falloir
quand même avoir il faut en avoir
conscience des moyens thermiques parce
que on va devoir sortir du charbon et
structurellement nos surcapacités de son
train de s'effacer alors que
l'électrification va progresser
on a un problème sur les prix
d'électricité et ça aussi on peut le
régler nous-mêmes mais on n'a pas le
luxe d'attendre trois ans pour le faire
j'étais à Bruxelles
il y a deux jours sur sur ce déballage
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça y est le
sujet du Market design il est maintenant
pris en compte alors que on le pensait
que ça le serait dans quelques années
mais arrêtez l'urgence est là parce que
on a une opportunité quand même qu'il
faut tout n'est pas noir c'est que
l'euro se déprécie très fortement c'est
évidemment ce qui contribue à renforcer
nos coûts de l'énergie apportée c'est
pour ça donc voilà mais c'est une
opportunité pour attirer des
investissements d'Europe mais quand vous
êtes investisseur asiatique la team
américain ou américain vous regardez là
vous dites ah oui c'est vrai le rose des
précis formidable opportunité mais d'un
autre côté on ne voit pas du tout où
vont aller les prix de l'électricité et
d'une manière structurelle ils sont
désormais les plus chers parmi les pays
de CDE donc vous dites attentisme et
j'investis aux US et j'aimerais vous
vous attirer votre attention sur ce
inflation
qui a été passé début août au milieu de
nos vacances
c'est une déclaration de guerre
économique des Américains c'est à dire
les Américains mettent plus de 300
milliards de dollars pour
soutenir le déploiement technologies bas
carbone made in USA
et on n'a pas vraiment d'équivalent
alors il y a énormément de choses qui
sont faites on y reviendra évidemment
dans un instant mais c'est d'une
puissance extraordinaire et leur
objectif c'est pas d'atteindre des
objectifs que nous nous fixons qui sont
hors d'atteinte en réalité non leur
objectif c'est de créer des emplois de
créer de la valeur de créer des chaînes
de valeur résilientes aux États-Unis
troisième mot sur les métaux bien alors
il faut bien avoir l'esprit que on sera
pas indépendant c'est une illusion en
indépendance énergétique l'indépendance
minérale faire des mines en Europe on
pourra en faire ici là mais les projets
sont trop petits sont pas rentables
bien sûr tout compte mais le sujet c'est
non il va falloir en fait aller
renforcer notre présence à l'étranger
avec des moyens politiques diplomatiques
financiers considérable des alliances
industrielles c'est ce qui est en train
un petit peu de se constituer à
Bruxelles mais
malheureusement on a 10 ans de retard
sur les Japonais et 50 retard sur les
Américains donc et dans ce milieu là
évidemment ça pèse énormément
sur le stockage des vernis c'est
absolument essentiel j'ai déjà dit
quelques mots
là aussi des initiatives vont être
prises mais d'une manière générale c'est
le sujet des infrastructures qui va
falloir reprendre pas seulement des
infrastructures hydrogène on ne parle
que de ça mais soyons réalistes on ne
peut pas faire de l'hydrogène qui est
réellement ba carbone avec le système
électrique qu'on a en ce moment et
surtout si on est
obsédé par l'hydrogène verte ça ne
marchera pas donc si on veut ce
décollage là soit on va à l'étranger
soit effectivement on se dit bon il va
falloir attendre encore un peu qu'on
décarbonne vraiment ce système
électrique et ensuite on mettra le
paquet dessus mais c'est voilà il y a un
dilemme là et je crois qu'il faut pas
non plus fermer totalement la porte à ce
que nous disent les Allemands sur les
importations encore une fois on n'aura
pas d'ammoniaque il faut emporter de
l'ammoniac et donc à terme il va dire
c'est à dire deux trois mots encore pour
vous dire que
cette politique industrielle elle va
devenir essentielle c'est à dire
maintenant le sujet c'est comment on
sauve nos industries énergo intensives
alors les Allemands ont mis le pied dans
le plat en disant 100 milliards par an
en grande partie pour cela ben
malheureusement oui en fait il y a pas
le choix parce que sinon c'est
l'hémorragie voilà et le problème c'est
que on est 27 pays membres et le risque
de fragmentation en Europe est plus
élevé que j'avais donc il va falloir
effectivement que d'autres étapes
puissent mobiliser de telle somme pour
sauver leurs industries pas seulement
les Allemands et éventuellement un petit
peu la France mais que tout le monde
puisse effectivement maniesta parce que
sinon on va avoir une fracture
territoriale etc qui va se renforcer
alors donc si vous voulez le mauvais
sage c'est de dire je crois qu'on va je
ne peux que conforter ce qualitoba on
est au on voit le sommet de l'iceberg
des crises tout cela va en fait se
renforcer s'inscrire dans la durée et
nous sommes en posture de drôles de
guerre alors qu'en fait c'est une vraie
mobilisation pour une dont on a besoin
et je prends un dernier juste un dernier
exemple en Autriche en France en
Allemagne en Espagne vous avez
énormément de projets hydro ENR qui sont
prêts à être lancés et pourquoi ils ne
le sont pas parce qu'il manque des
autorisations parce qu'il manque
l'interconnexion électrique parce qu'il
manque je ne sais quel signature parce
que je ne sais qui n'est pas d'accord
mais c'est inadmissible c'est
inadmissible c'est pas possible c'est un
peu comme si les Ukrainiens face à
l'avance et russe en leur disait bah oui
mais en fait on a oublié de balayer le
hangar où sont l'émulsion donc on sort
pas l'émission non mais c'est ça c'est
totalement absurde et donc voilà cette
posture là quand j'évoque cette
mobilisation pour une économie de guerre
c'est vraiment tout cela qu'il faut
absolument d'urgence finalement je vous
remercie pour votre attention
Maria Eugenia Sana maître de conférence
en économie de l'université Paris-Saclay
alors pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur
l'avenir énergétique de l'Union
européenne et les moyens de répondre à
l'urgence climatique dans le contexte de
la crise de l'énergie ça fait une belle
transition avec avec l'intervention
précédente
OK et
après par rapport à Marc-Antoine
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec et ce
qui était dit sur les
les
le fait que il faut sauver notre notre
secteur industriel et que à ces
moments-là il faut penser à des moyens
thermiques mais à différents de des
marques Antoine je pense que on doit
justement dégager des donc on doit
massivement et comme Thomas l'a dit
investir
les thermiques à des secteurs où on peut
vraiment pas de carboner notamment la
défense
ok donc où les moyens thermiques sont
effectivement les plus efficaces et ça
serait stupide des faire une transition
pour des chars par exemple d'accord
j'arrive voilà donc pour répondre à la
question
qui m'a été posée il me semble que la
meilleure façon de regarder ça c'est de
regarder quelles sont les volets
principaux de Reaper moi ils sont 4 donc
il a on a le back-stop donc le mécanisme
pour
des solidarités entre pays européens
dans le cas où on aurait plus de gaz
russe
mes collègues ont évoqué et ça risque de
passer de problèmes et il va mettre la
solidarité européenne à l'épreuve on a
eu
en juillet qu'on en a parlé de diminuer
des 10% la consommation de gaz au niveau
européen
Bruxelles a
cette proposition et la ministre
espagnol des raisins écologiques a
répondu
l'Espagne ne se passe au-delà de ses
possibilités
en disant voilà nous on va pas réduire
de 10% pour sauver donc il y a c'est un
jeu qui est vous savez citer des
choix souverains qu'on a fait le
cheminement qu'on a qui en a pris pour
le mix énergétique qui en a aujourd'hui
et Madon on est confronté à cette
problématique avec des pays qui ont fait
des choix très différents avec des coûts
et des risques par exemple le risque de
nucléaire différent mais on est
confronté au même problématiques et donc
ça risque de d'avoir d'être très
difficile donc le volet
c'est voler là de backstop pour le gaz
risque d'être très compliqué et mettre
la solidarité européenne à l'épreuve
et donc il nous reste les ultravolets
qui sont efficacité énergétiques
diversification des sources énergétiques
et
le hausse dans le dans l'objectif de
renouvelables après il y a plus de
détails mais bon moi je ferai la
synthèse
donc comme c'est le 4e il risque d'être
difficile effectivement il faut
travailler sur les sur les autres 3
l'efficacité énergétique pourquoi c'est
une bonne idée parce que dans le court
terme l'offre elle est donnée donc la
seule façon qu'un peu on a des diminué
les coûts c'est de diminuer la demande
et là la fausse bonne idée c'est de
faire juste de l'exhortation en ces
moments j'allume
la radio et on parle de comment on peut
faire pour réduire degré il y a des
méta-analyses fait par des experts même
avec des messieurs qui ne sont pas qui
sont des blessures incitatives juste
avec des prix des différentiels des prix
pas très importants et les il y a aucun
étude que trouve plus de
4,5% de des économies dans le ménage et
bon les économies peuvent arriver
jusqu'à 15% dans le secteur industriel
mais ça dépend de secteur donc il nous
faut un état stratège donc chez Marie de
d'être ici aujourd'hui parce que il nous
faut une politique claire
d'efficacité énergétique et donc pour
les bâtiments publics c'est facile c'est
des mandats pour les pour les les saints
industriels et les ménages il faut pas
oublier comme on dit mes collègues le
signal prix donc il faut laisser le prix
montrer le signal et protéger que les
vulnérables que les secteurs qui sont
vraiment
énergivores etc donc si on veut avoir
une véritable efficacité énergétique il
faut avoir une politique d'efficacité
énergétique
laissez le prix qui est un prix très
élevé et
travailler c'est à dire je veux pas
prendre un chat privé si effectivement
ça m'écoute 20 fois plus cher que
prendre la face classe de
il y a plein de plein de plein de
questions que pour être résolus si on
laissait les plus aisés voir le vrai
prix des synergies et il y a d'ailleurs
un étude qui a fait avec une de mes
étudiantes ou on montre que par exemple
la remise à la pompe
bénéficie presque trois fois plus les
plus riches qu'elle est plus pauvres
donc
et exactement donc il faut réfléchir il
faut pas il faut et donc comme a dit
Thomas l'efficacité énergétique
on peut pas faire de la ficase
énergétique avec un bouclier tarifaire
ou avec une remise à la pompe il faut
faire de l'efficacité génétique avec un
signal prix et les prix intelligents tu
veux pas me répéter
et comme a dit Marc-Antoine on est dans
un moment très difficile il faut que la
politique soit à l'auteur de cette de
cet enjeu d'accord donc ça c'est pour
pour l'efficacité d'intérieur critique
que c'est une très bonne idée je répète
parce que diminuer la consommation ça
coûte rien
ok ça coûte juste les donc déjà au début
ça coûte rien et même tous les tous les
investissements qui ont fera seront pour
avoir un coût de moyen long terme plus
faible
diversification des ressources donc le
deuxième volet dont je voulais parler
donc le texte il est écrit
d'une façon ça nous fait penser à
diversifier nos partenaires commerciaux
sur les énergies fossiles
ok pour le
vraiment à cet instant ok mais ça peut
pas être notre stratégie de
diversification de sources donc en
marquant toi a raison
ça va être très difficile d'avoir
beaucoup tous les mines dont on aurait
besoin
en Europe donc la diversification de
source
c'est plutôt diversifier nos partenaires
commerciaux sur les métaux
et stratégiques à cette transition sur
certains métaux ça va être très
difficile cobalt graphite
ça sera compliqué vu là où se trouve les
mines et
des métaux rares des sauts de métaux
comme les lithiums sont pas des métaux
rares et aucune raison pour que ces
lithium soit produits dans la plupart en
Australie à la grande majorité en
Australie et au Chili et après soit
chipé en Chine pour qu'il fasse nos
batteries et pour qu'après nous on
laisse un porte nous on peut tout à fait
et il y a des accords l'accord franc
calmant sur les gigafactories il faut
pousser encore plus loin si vous voulez
là
et
juste pour vous donner d'ailleurs
un élément intéressant par rapport à
cette question des donc l'hydrogène vert
tous tous les choses que on s'est dit
tous ces options que c'est dit ça va pas
ça va ils vont pas nous sortir du cours
court terme en fait
je suis une étudiante aussi qui fait sa
thèse sur les hogène vert pour les
secteurs industriels donc là votre rôle
en avec le contact et dans les
collectivités locales et très importante
parce que les
ces types des innovations notamment
l'implémentation de l'hydrogène verte
les lettolyse c'est
ça va coupler avec une politique
industrielle sectorielle et donc votre
travail il est très important parce que
effectivement pour certains secteur avec
les prix des synergies fossiles qui vont
rester durablement élevé notamment le
gaz
effectivement ça devient intéressant et
et on a des plus en plus de cas d'études
sur l'hydrogène vert grâce à cette à
cette situation actuelle donc
pour assumer vis-à-vis à par rapport à
la question de la diversification des
sources il faut diversifier
véritablement des sources il faut pas
diversifier les partenaires il faut
diversifier les partenaires d'un des
sautes métaux comme vous savez bien
souligner et
métaux et autres matériaux importants et
effectivement on a les moyens pour pour
dans certains cas ça serait tout à fait
possible parce que ce n'est pas que ils
sont produits dans des pays qui nous
sont hostiles ou qui sont voilà mais il
faut rattraper le retard parce que on a
parlé de des sauts de pays occidentaux
qui sont
qui ont déjà des et pris la main mais la
Chine a plus de 20 ans de d'avance sur
ces types de
de des métaux et ces ressources
même pas je parle pas de des cils qui
sont en Chine voilà et juste
en dernière point parce que on parlait
de au début
donc il a été la question il y avait
trois questions le nucléaire on a déjà
parlé les métaux stratégiques qu'on a
aussi un peu parlé il nous restait le
stockage comme
comme
l'importance stratégique de le stockage
en fait le stockage électrique
pour l'instant donc effectivement on
voit des plus en plus déployer le
déploiement des du stockage électrique à
grande échelle et
il faut il y a des études qui montrent
leur efficacité qu'on s'est couplé avec
l'investissement en réseau que c'est le
grand oublié de cette crise le resto
électrique ok donc les centaires
collections même à l'intérieur de la
France on pourrait beaucoup améliorer en
termes d'interconnexion pour
l'interconnexion améliore l'efficacité
nous permet de connecter plus de
renouvelables et donc il faut pas
l'oublier c'est quelque chose de très
important et
finalement chose pour conclure donc par
rapport à ces volets le grand il me
semble la grande barrière pour la
l'installation massive de renouvelables
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas les
financements
des études sur les finances vertes et
effectivement l'attractivité des
énergies
renouvelables dans les marchés
financiers on monte avec avec condilia
une crise de cet ordre là d'ailleurs
j'ai un travail fait aussi avec une un
de mes étudiants qui montrent ça
et donc
par rapport à ça
et mais une grande barrière elle a été
soulignée par Thomas c'est et
l'accélération des permis pour pour
pouvoir implémenter beaucoup de
renouvelables etc et c'est très
important et
il faut pas oublier non plus que il y a
des contraintes environnementales liées
au déploiement de ces de ces énergies et
donc la meilleure façon d'accélérer
je vois que une partie des barrières
sont liées à la bureaucratie mais il a
une autre partie qui sont liées à des
contraintes environnementales
concrètes il faut il me semble c'est
pour ça que je suis très contente d'être
ici aujourd'hui que vous puissiez
entamer le dialogue pour il y a de il y
a des études fait par l'îlot par exemple
qui montre le bénéfice des déplaiements
de ces salariés au niveau en termes des
professionnels de la main d'oeuvre etc
donc il faut que vous puissiez entamer
ces dialogues et parler de ces bénéfices
au niveau local pour effectivement
réussir cette transition
merci merci juste un petit point par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit sur le
fait que la remise à la pompe bénéficie
finalement à ceux qui ont le plus de
moyens
ça sur une vue macroéconomique je suis
d'accord mais quand on revient au
territoire et qu'on analyse la situation
notamment dans les milieux ruraux où les
gens modestes utilisent leur véhicule
pour aller travailler l'impact sur le
porte-monnaie de l'aide à la pompe il
est il est très très important
oui en fait dans l'étude on regarde la
différence entre Essonne
urbaine périurbaine rural avec grand
plaisir je peux le donner effectivement
ma cinquième propose dans le papier
c'est ce qu'on appelle des boucliers
ciblés c'est-à-dire une progression et
qui change aussi parce que on fait ça on
dégage des ressources qu'on peut
utiliser pour le changement de mode de
transport pour inciter à changer par
exemple par des voitures électriques par
l'utilisation des des transports en
commun etc
il faut
mais ce que je voulais vous dire c'est
en volume effectivement ça peut ça peut
bénéficier aux gens les plus aisés mais
en impact
c'est important pour les gens les plus
modestes
en volume d'argent voilà
en fait c'est un enjeu de ce qu'on
économie on appelle le coût
d'opportunité c'est à dire que le tarif
le bouclier tarifaire l'année prochaine
il coûterait environ 45 milliards en
tout cas c'est ce qui a été
budgété 45 milliards si jamais vous
ciblez ça sur les 10 millions des
Français les plus pauvres par exemple
vous êtes dans 4000 euros vous êtes sur
4000 euros par personne par an donc la
question c'est quelle est la meilleure
manière d'utiliser l'argent public voilà
là pour l'instant il y a eu un mécanisme
effectivement qui arrose absolument tout
le monde et sur la question du pétrole
les gens qui consomment le plus sont les
gens que les voitures les plus lourdes
et les gens que les voitures les plus
lourdes sont les plus riches donc c'est
vraiment cet enjeu là du coup
d'opportunité c'est bien ce que je
disais en volume c'est plus important là
mais en impact c'est peut-être
l'impact on peut c'est facile la cibler
on sait on sait qui habite dans une
région donc quand vous déclarez des
impôts pour être très simple vous
déclarez on sait où vous quel est votre
activité c'est par exemple vous savez
une voiture de fonction tout ça le
ciblage serait très simple et on
pourrait d'ailleurs pour les personnes
qui sont les plus Sécession veut pas les
pénaliser autant parce que ils font
partie de on pourrait les aider à
transformer leur forme de d'utilisation
merci votre étude nous intéresse
madame
Tatiana marquez
uriarté donc membre du cabinet
de
quadrille Simpson donc commissaire
européen
oui bonjour monsieur le Président Madame
la Présidente
effectivement je travaille dans les
cabinets de du commissaire pour
l'énergie je m'occupe des surtout du gaz
et de l'hydrogène mais depuis un an plus
que rien d'autre sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et sur les prix de
l'énergie
je voudrais toucher sur trois points
aujourd'hui d'abord j'aimerais bien
expliquer un petit peu qu'est-ce qui a
changé ou combien le système énergétique
européenne a changé dans les dernières
années
deuxièmement j'aimerais bien évoquer un
peu les blessures que l'Union européenne
a déjà prise pour s'attaquer à ce crise
énergétique Christ approvisionnement et
Chris de prix et troisièmement j'ai
méridiens avancer un peu quels sont
selon nous
les perspectives c'est à dire c'est ce
qui reste à faire et on croit qu'il y en
a encore beaucoup à faire pour nous
sortir de cette crise ou
au moins pour essayer de le faire
d'abord qu'est-ce qui a changé cette
année
beaucoup de choses ont changé beaucoup
plus de c'est ce qu'on a vu dans les si
vous prenez les dernières années
sur les gaz nos partenaires commerciaux
ont complètement changé
avant un an notre principal apporte
exportateur des gaz était la Russie
si on regarde combien de gaz arriver par
gazeux jusqu'à 2021 était autour de 40%
de notre de nos importations
aujourd'hui c'est la Norvège le pays
on importe le plus par casque
et nous sommes dépendants simplement à 7
points 5% du casque de la Russie en ce
qui concerne les garçons
si on regarde ensemble du gaz russe donc
à ce duc + engie plus donc les coups de
pied on se fait autour de
14%. donc ça complètement changé
deuxièmement c'est ce qui a changé aussi
c'est la direction de flou donc
traditionnellement on a importé les gaz
de la Russie et on les transportait par
nos gasoducts de l'est à l'ouest
maintenant on fait l'inverse
et pas toujours les
infrastructures glaciaires étaient
préparées à ça parce que il faut avoir
des directions inverse
aujourd'hui on utilise beaucoup plus les
gaz les utilisant les terminales
gaciaires de l'ouest et du sud de
l'Europe et on les transporte au centre
et à l'est de l'Europe donc déjà ça a
complètement changé
notre fournisseur d'électricité des des
gaz de cuisine été traditionnellement
les États-Unis c'est encore le cas mais
avec des volumes qui ont battu des
records de la dernière année donc
maintenant c'est clair que nous sommes
complètement dépendants
du gaz liquidifier qui nous envoie les
États-Unis heureusement qu'ils ont
augmenté
leur volume d'exportation sans
lesquelles ce serait très difficile pour
nous de continuer à voir la consommation
que nous avons actuellement
sur les prix de du gaz je n'avais pas
m'attarder là-dessus parce que je crois
que Thomas il a il a déjà très bien
expliqué ce qui s'est passé dans la
dernière année
notre
évaluation de des causes de cette de
cette augmentation
c'est très partagé par c'est la même en
fait que les principales institutions
d'abord en début de
l'automne fin de l'été 2021 c'était la
sortie du covid de restrictions du covid
donc une très grande augmentation de
l'aliment de du gaz globalement surtout
en assis ensuite les tensions avec la
Russie
ont inspiré la situation et après
l'invasion de l'Ukraine disons ça fait
les prix complètement flambés
dans l'électricité
les prix de l'électricité comme Thomas
évoqué ils sont entraînés par les prix
de gaz et ça parce que nous sommes
encore comme on a déjà répété très
dépendant des combustibles fossiles
notamment du gaz il inclut pour la
production d'électricité
donc
comme résultat c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est que beaucoup des pays européens et
encore plus les pays en dehors de
l'Europe ils ont commencé à regarder au
delà du gaz et à produire de
l'électricité aussi à partir d'autres
combustibles fossiles
notamment les charbon donc encore plus
polluante que
le gaz est polluant
l'évolution que nous voyons pour les
prochains années c'est effectivement
pas très positif dans les sens où nous
croyons que au moins jusqu'à ce que la
guerre continue on va avoir ces prix de
gaz très haut parce que la Russie
continue à manipuler les prix il en fait
comme ça a été dit probablement depuis
2014 et effectivement dans ces dernières
années tout ce qui tout ce qu'on a vu
c'était c'était vraiment très clair
en dehors des sabotages d'une enreg la
Russie et la couper les robinets a
beaucoup d'États il y a beaucoup de
compagnies qui a porté du gaz
et on ne prévoit pas que ça va améliorer
dans les dans les prochains années ça va
continuer à avoir une tension permanente
quelle a été donc la réponse de l'Europe
face à cette crise
d'abord c'est ce qu'on a décidé c'est
d'échanger complémentaires
jusqu'à maintenant
comme on a déjà évoqué on était très
dépendant du gaz russe on a pris la
décision qu'on avait plus l'être
et donc
on veut l'arrêt total de importation des
combustibles fossiles hautes de la
Russie aussi vite que possible ça c'est
la première décision qui a pris l'Union
européenne comment comme disait en
regardant sur trois volets d'abord les
diversification ensuite les
renouvelables donc promotion des
renouvelables augmentation de nos
objectifs dans les renouvelables et
troisièmement aussi augmentation de nos
objectifs qualification énergétique pour
améliorer
l'efficacité de notre consommation
la deuxième chose que la l'Union
européenne a commencé à faire dans cette
crise et de se préparer pour les pires
les pires c'est la fin totale des flux
du gaz de la Russie
et aussi on est là de ça peut-être
d'autres incidences qui peuvent se
produire ça suffit qu'il y a un problème
dans une terminale gaciaire aux
États-Unis comme on a vu avant l'été où
qu'il y ait des problèmes dans dans une
ligne un gâteau à l'intérieur de
l'Europe on peut avoir des gros
problèmes de
des approvisionnements
donc sur ces volets qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait d'abord on a établi les obligations
de stockage de gaz parce que il faut se
préparer
autant que possible avant le début de
chaque hiver et comme ça a été dit
l'année prochaine probablement sera plus
plus difficile et peut-être plus cher
des remplir nos notre stockage des gaz
parce qu'on aura peut-être pas le gaz
rouge
deuxièmement on a réduit et on a établi
des obligations pour réduire la
consommation des gaz en Europe
d'abord d'une façon volontaire on
établit un plan cet été pour dire on
veut qu'elle est un membre diminue de
15% leur consommation
malheureusement on n'est pas encore là
on est à 7%
. et donc il faut faire plus efforts la
Commission européenne disons dans ce
règlement à un instrument dans la poche
qui est la possibilité de déclarer
l'état d'alerte qui ne donnerait la
possibilité de faire que c'est objectif
volontaire pour l'instant puissent venir
obligatoire
et troisièmement c'est ce qu'on a fait
c'est améliorer la coordination entre
les États membres en question de
sécurité d'approvisionnement nous avons
des réunions nous avons établies
disons un cabinet d'écrit si vous voulez
l'appeler comme ça ou les représentants
de cet arbre se réunissent presque tous
les semaines pour en discuter de la
situation de l'approvisionnement de gaz
donc de façon il y a un disons un
échange constant si jamais il y a des
incidents si jamais il y a des problèmes
avec la Russie gastrom ou d'autres
fournisseurs on y partage et aussi on
s'entraide dans les sens où peut-être il
faut demander de l'aide des voisins pour
donner des réponses à des à des manques
d'énergie spécifique
la troisième chose qu'on a fait c'est
donc j'ai évoqué le changer les caps
deuxièmement
[Musique]
complètement
se préparer pour les pires donc les
problèmes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et troisièmement on
est en train d'agir sur les prix d'abord
on s'est attaqué à l'électricité on a
adopté c'est moins de septembre des
mesures d'urgence
pour diminuer les prix de l'électricité
des Européens
ça comporte ses paquets
4 mesures principales la première et
d'établir des objectifs de réduction des
la consommation d'électricité cette
fois-ci
surtout dans des moments des points donc
vraiment où on a une grosse consommation
d'électricité et où une réduction des 7
consommation pourrait faire en sorte
qu'on n'a pas à faire court aux plantes
d'électricité à base de gaz qui sont les
plus coûteuses donc afin de diminuer les
prix pour tous les pour tout la
production du de l'électricité
deuxièmement il y a une deuxième essieu
qui est des limitée les revenus des
générateurs d'électricité qu'on appelle
inframmarginaux c'est-à-dire ceux qui
sont moins coûteux
que le gaz que les plantes électriques
du gaz pourquoi parce que effectivement
comme les prix du marché établit par les
technologies les plus chères donc les
centrales électriques au gaz tous ceux
qui ont des coûts qui ont des clous des
coups moindres ils ont de grosses
revenus
cette année parce qu'ils sont payés
comme si c'était en train de produire
électricité à partir du gaz
et donc
c'est ce qu'on a proposé et ça a été
accepté par la par les conseils et des
établir un cap établir un plat un
plafond à ce que c'est générateur un
frais marginaux pouvait recevoir dans
les marchés électriques
ça produisent des revenus pour les États
membres qui peut s'utiliser ces
différences entre le prix du marché et
les plafonnement pour financer leur
mesure des soutien aux consommateurs
donc par exemple des prix reculés pour
l'électricité à certains types de
consommateurs ou des soutiens pour faire
des blessures d'efficacité énergétique
ou d'autres
troisième est sûr on a donné la
possibilité on l'a reconnu dans la
législation des données des prix
réguliers pour l'électricité non
simplement pour les foyers et pour les
micro-entreprises mais aussi pour les
PME donc ça c'est aujourd'hui possible
avant c'était pas possible dans notre
règlement d'électricité donc
temporairement on peut aussi aider le
PME et finalement on a établi une
contribution des solidarités à charge
des compagnies productrices des
combustibles et fossiles et des
raffineries afin que elle aussi
contribue à payer ou à aider les plus
vulnérables les consommateurs à payer
les gros prix
de l'électricité
finalement qu'est-ce qui reste à faire
selon nous il reste beaucoup à faire
parce que pour l'instant on s'est
surtout attaqué au prix de l'électricité
et on voudrait aussi s'attaquer au prix
de gaz
et dans les prochains jours la
Commission va adopter une proposition
aussi une proposition d'urgence parce
que on est vraiment dans une situation
d'urgence
ou on prévoit de prendre des
dispositions pour essayer de diminuer
les prix du gaz et surtout aussi la
volatilité les marchés du gaz la
première mesure qui aura là c'est de
créer un index alternatif quotidienne
c'est l'index nous avons aujourd'hui
pour établir la plupart des
contrats commerciaux des ventes du gaz
il utilise pour établir la formule des
prix
mais les titillets est un index qui est
surtout basé sur les prix du gaz dans le
marché hollandais
qui à ce moment-là
malheureusement il a beaucoup de
difficultés parce qu'il reçoit moins de
gaz russe parce qu'elle est gaz russes
diminué et parce que il y a des
problèmes dans les infrastructures
surtout des raisons pour recevoir plus
de gaz liquides on s'en fait que dans
les marchés hollandais les prix du gaz
sont très hauts et donc un conséquence
ça fait que pour tous ceux qui avaient
indexé leur contrat avec le prix du TTF
le prix de gaz qu'il s'achète c'est
extrêmement cher surtout un comparant
avec c'est ce qui paye donc
d'autres économies nos concurrences à
Nancy ou ailleurs
dans la première chose qu'on veut faire
c'est d'établir à l'index alternatif
quelque chose qui puisse être utilisé
par les acteurs économiques qui passent
des contrats des fournitures des gaz qui
reflètent plus les vrais prix du gaz du
gaz liquidifier en Europe qui sont
beaucoup plus bas en réalité que le
prix que nous avons à nous rendre à ces
moments-là
mais établir ces index ça va nous
prendre un petit temps donc jusqu'à
l'année prochaine on sera pas capable de
la voir
et entre temps c'est pour ça que nous
prévoyons aussi d'établir des
limitations des prix
à tous les gaz qui va être importés à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne aussi
bien les gaz les cuir que le gaz
les gaz qui vient par exemple
c'est ce qu'on prévoit c'est des
engagés négociations avec nos
partenaires commerciaux qui sont pas la
Russie
pour essayer de diminuer les prix de du
gaz qu'on achète aujourd'hui ça c'est
difficile mais si les négociations
n'aboutissent pas on aura toujours la
possibilité
d'établir un plafonnement un prix
maximal à ce que au gaz qu'on va acheter
bien sûr ça comporte des risques parce
que dans une négociation
qui n'aboutissent pas si on décide
d'établir à un prix maximal peut-être on
n'aura pas tous les gaz dont on a besoin
c'est pour ça qu'on est en train de
regarder aussi si on ne devrait pas
prendre des messieurs aussi plus
contraignants en ce qui concerne la
réduction de la consommation de gaz si
jamais ça devait se produire donc il
faut se préparer aussi à un moment où si
vraiment on pousse la question de prix
on leur a peut-être certains problèmes
de fournitures dans certaines parties de
l'Europe
troisièmement
nous voulons prendre des mesures des
solidarités en français entre les États
membres
parce que si effectivement il y a des
problèmes des fournitures dans certains
partis de l'Europe il va falloir
s'entraider il va falloir que les États
membres qui ont du gaz peuvent donner du
gaz à ceux dont on n'ont pas de gaz par
exemple parce qu'il dépendent trop du
gaz russe
et non pas assez surtout pour
remplir les besoins de ce qu'on appelle
les consommateurs protégés donc vraiment
par exemple les foyers
ou les industries critiques donc en état
qui
est voisin et qui n'a pas tellement de
problèmes normalement devrait pouvoir
aider ceux qui ont plus de problèmes
même si ça signifie qu'il doit réduire
la consommation de ces consommateurs non
protégés
ça c'est le principe
ça dépend jusqu'à maintenant c'est une
solidarité des accords bilatéraux entre
les États membres donc on est en train
de réfléchir si on a on ne devrait pas
faire cette solidarité
plus un automatisme que quelque chose
qui dépend de ses accords bilatéraux qui
pour l'instant malheureusement sont très
peu il devrait être beaucoup plus
et finalement on va prendre des
blessures pour opérationnaliser les
achats conjoints de gaz donc ça a été
évoqué déjà dans les passer nous
considérons que une possibilité aussi
pour faire que les prix
diminuent c'est que les États membres
les compagnies européennes s'effacent
pas la concurrence dans l'achat de
l'achat de gaz
pour donner un exemple si vous allez à
nager ces jours là vous allez trouver
des Français des Italiens la Commission
européenne tous en train d'essayer
d'avoir plus de gaz
et le mois d'août quand nous avons les
États membres des V a commencé à remplir
très fortement leur capacité de stockage
de gaz on a vu une flambée des prix du
gaz parce que tout on a couru au même un
fournisseur pour acheter différemment on
s'est vraiment fait la concurrence cette
coordination des Comores et quand
remplir les stockage de gaz nous devons
la faire mieux nous devons la faire
mieux et une des façons de le faire
c'est probablement en achetant aussi
conjointement donc on va prendre
monsieur créer les cadres juridiques
pour que les États membres et les
compagnies qui veulent acheter ensemble
puissent le faire
et
ça c'est plutôt les blessures qu'on veut
prendre immédiatement mais nous
regardons ailleurs par exemple très tôt
nous pensons que ça va être possible de
adopter aussi des blessures pour
améliorer la liquidité des entreprises
énergétiques qui participent dans les
marchés des futurs d'énergie
vous seriez entendu ça est arrivé dans
beaucoup des pays ça commençait dans la
chouette mais après dans un dans
d'autres pays tous ces compagnies
énergétiques qui
participent aussi dans les marchés des
futurs d'énergie ils ont eu des
problèmes de liquidité donc ils peuvent
ils pouvaient pas ils savaient pas assez
d'argent pour pouvoir participer dans
ces marchés parce que les règles du
marché leur demandaient des grosses
sommes d'argent pour pouvoir garantir
que les transactions dans les futurs
allaient se faire comme les prix ils ont
augmenté les garanties ont monté aussi
et donc on est en train de regarder
comment élargir par exemple les types de
collatéraux les types de garanties qu'on
peut donner pour participer dans ce
marché par exemple aujourd'hui
apparemment ils peuvent simplement
fournir des liquidités des caches on est
en train de regarder s'ils peuvent pas
garantir aussi avec des et qui dit donc
des vraiment des biens
ou avoir des garanties de l'État par
exemple donc on voudra on va modifier
les règles des d'états pour s'assurer
que les États membres puissent donner
des garanties publiques à ces
entreprises
aussi on regarde un système de c'est ce
qu'on appelle un circuit breakers donc
mettre un franc
à une flambée et spontanée donc
augmentation de prix de l'électricité
par exemple dans les marchés donc
arrêtez les marchés arrêtez la
cotisation si vous voulez comment ça se
passe dans les marchés financière quand
ça
pousse une certaine limite pour que les
autorités régulatrices se posent la
question de savoir si c'est normal et
c'est pas normal il y a un mouvement en
spéculatif une manipulation des prix et
puis recommencer quand les conditions
sont à nouveau rétablies pour pouvoir
avoir vraiment une une un échange de
offres et des mondes qui soient
raisonnable
et finalement pour l'année prochaine
nous passons aussi à revisser les règles
du marché d'électricité
parce que c'est un les
dessins que nous avons jusqu'à
maintenant ça beaucoup davantage ça nous
donner la possibilité qu'on a ça a été
dit d'avoir des prix de l'électricité
très bas pendant très longtemps mais il
faut s'assurer que ça va continuer dans
les temps aussi quand nous aurions un
système électrique très dépendant de des
renouvelables
donc nous voulons des prix qui
continuent à être bas parce que est en
train de passer dans ces dernières
années et nous voulions quand même que
le système continue à donner des
encouragements au s'investissement des
renouvelables donc ça doit trouver
l'équilibre entre donner l'encouragement
au s'investissement mais aussi avoir des
prix d'électricité qui soit abordable
conclusion je voudrais finir par dire
que dans l'Union européenne nous avons
compris à la Commission européenne qui
est dans les temps exceptionnels qu'on
est en train de vivre nous en savons
besoin de mesures exceptionnels donc
vraiment notre mentalité est vraiment la
métalité d'un d'une situation de guerre
nous avons adopté des mesures d'urgence
pour l'électricité nous allons adopter
des mesures d'urgence pour les gaz mais
il faut savoir que notre direction
un moyen long terme
n'a pas bougé c'est à dire on a
on a accepté que pendant un certain
temps probablement la consommation de
comme si les fossiles va déplacer
le gaz donc des combustible plus
polluants la déplacer les gars pour des
raisons de sécurité d'approvisionnement
et pour des raisons des prix mais
notre objectif final est vraiment la
carbonisation du système parce que nous
croyons que c'est la façon de réunir la
sécurité d'approvisionnement la
compétitivité des prix de l'énergie et
la lutte contre les changements
climatiques c'est quelque chose sur
laquelle on veut continuer à travailler
et finalement simplement dire que il va
falloir faire des sacrifices dans les
prochains années
et les sacrifices vont être d'un côté de
voir réduire notre consommation donc
faire des choix sur vraiment les
situations critiquent pour lesquelles on
avait soins de l'énergie que nous avons
si jamais il faut décider et
deuxièmement il va falloir
que les États membres montrent toute
leur solidarité les ont envers les
autres parce qu'autrement on sera la
suite situation où
les pressions externes
pour nous définir seront trop fort
c'est la parole à Daniel grimillet qui
est notre spécialiste énergie un des
spécialistes énergies
le président de la groupe d'études
d'énergie
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le Président je remercie nos quatre
invités nos quatre intervenants
spécialiste est un grand mot je j'ai
travaillé avec d'autres collègues et
notamment avec ma collègue Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne où nous avons travaillé
sur un rapport complet sur le volet
énergie du paquet ajustement 55 on a
retiré trois enseignements le premier
c'est le besoin d'accorder une plus
grande attention à la question du coup
l'énergie
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps mais
franchement il est pas abordé et le
citoyen l'entreprise n'est vraiment pas
prise en compte sur le côté
supportabilité le deuxième enseignement
c'est l'impératif de respecter les
compétences
car ce paquet propose parfois des
objectifs des moyens inadaptés deux
exemples tirés des directives sur les
énergies innovables l'exemple 45%
d'énergie renouvelable d'ici 2030
installé des panneaux photovoltaïques
tous les bâtiments vie commerciaux et
les anciens neuf c'est clairement
inatteignable de 2030
le dernier enseignement c'est le la
nécessité de garantir une plus grande
neutralité technologique car ce paquet
laisse de côté l'énergie et l'hydrogène
nucléaire bien sûr mais aussi
l'hydroélectricité
nous avons eu le plaisir d'entendre
quand même un intervenant qui est l'a
évoqué où les bioénergie ainsi le
Règlement sur les carburants alternatifs
ou les initiatives sur l'aérien ou les
maritimes sont focalisés sur les
traumabilité sans se soucier du biogaz
ou des biocarburants c'est un tort car
ce paquet suppose de doubler notre
production d'exciter pour être réaliste
réalisé ne mettons pas tous les œufs
dans les mêmes paniers nous pouvons-nous
nous pensons nous que ces questions de
soustabilité de subsidiarité de
neutralité devrait être davantage prise
en compte c'est ça la vraie question
à notre niveau
merci alors je voulais donner la parole
à Claude Kern il y a Pierre Laurent
peut-être qui voulait s'exprimer il
était là pire comme tu es où
oui je merci pour pour toutes ces
introductions avec des constats très
intéressants je voulais
évoquer de deux questions qui n'ont pas
été
évoquer en tout cas ces termes
qui me paraissent importante parce que
vous avez parlé
des ta stratège d'investissement massifs
nécessaires
et on sait que les murs d'investissement
sont considérables
quel que soit d'ailleurs les options
qu'on est sur le mix énergétique dans
tous les cas de figure on est face à des
besoins d'investissement
extrêmement important
or
on vit encore sous le régime
de toute une série de politiques
européennes qui ont conduit et poussés à
la déréglementation et à la concurrence
et qui ont affaibli nos moyens stratèges
moi je prends la France nos grands
opérateurs industriels sont soit
hors de des politiques stratégiques et
public il faudrait construire soit ils y
sont encore mais très affaiblis par
toutes ces politiques là
donc est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
privilégie vraiment des politiques de
planification stratégique en y mettant
les moyens ou est-ce qu'on continue de
de bricoler et d'inventer moi je le
ressens comme ça perpétuellement au
niveau de la Commission européenne en
particulier ce que je viens d'entendre
de me rassure pas des sortes d'usine à
gaz et de bricolage pour faire avec ce
qu'on a fait depuis 20 ans alors qu'il
s'agit aujourd'hui de répondre à des
problèmes stratégiques d'une toute autre
ampleur auquel on peut pas réfléchir
uniquement avec ça ça c'est une première
remarque la deuxième remarque que je
veux faire c'est sur l'international
ce que vous dites et je crois que c'est
vrai il va falloir travailler tout à
fait différemment à l'international en
tout cas il va falloir envisager cette
dimension
même en ayant l'ambition d'une véritable
souveraineté européenne nous allons être
confrontés à ces il va falloir traiter
ces questions or là aussi je pense qu'il
faut se dire les choses si on veut le
faire il va falloir changer les modes de
rapport internationaux que nous avons
sur ces questions
parce que les pays auxquels nous allons
nous adresser et les sources ont eux
aussi des enjeux de développement
considérables ils sont plus ils sont
même plus confrontés que nous et aux
enjeux climatiques et aux enjeux états
génétiques et aujourd'hui donc si nous
ne leur offrons pas des rapports
internationaux qui leur permettent à eux
aussi de résoudre leurs problèmes je ne
vois pas pourquoi ils accepteraient les
jusqu'ici on a vécu sur des rapports qui
étaient en fait des rapports de
domination de prédation ou de dépendance
et quand on était en situation de
dépendance on utilisait ses dépendances
pour en faire des alliés stratégiques et
donc on est dans l'aberration
aujourd'hui par exemple de nos rapports
avec avec les pays du Golfe
qui du point de vue énergétique sont
sont aberrants
alors que entre guillemets c'est nos
alliés internationaux
quoi que j'en pense par ailleurs mais
c'est pas le sujet du débat mais si on
veut d'autres si on veut traiter les
sujets ça ne peut pas être sur ce type
de rapport par exemple la question des
transferts de technologie la question
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
offre à ces pays comme modèle de
développement qui résolvent leurs
problèmes qui d'ailleurs au plan
climatique par exemple sont aussi en
vérité les nôtres quand on voit ce qui
vient de se passer au Pakistan
un pays noyé sous les eaux qui n'est pas
un pays c'est pas le pays le plus pauvre
du monde une telle on peut pas donc moi
je pense que
poser les questions vous posez qui sont
à mes yeux très réels oblige à
s'interroger sur les modèles de
coopération internationaux qui sont les
nôtres des modèles le rapport
internationaux et à dernière remarque
que je veux faire c'est à plusieurs
reprises certains d'entre vous ont parlé
des vulnérables de la protection des
vulnérables
moi j'aimerais qu'on soit maintenant
plus précis sur ces questions parce que
les vulnérables ils sont très très
nombreux
ils sont même probablement l'immense
majorité des pays face à ces enjeux au
plan international et ils sont dans nos
sociétés l'immense majorité de la
société
donc c'est pas on fait comme ça avec des
signals prix très élevés etc puis on va
s'occuper de une petite partie qui
serait en difficulté
c'est qu'en vérité les vulnérables face
à ces crises là c'est l'immense majorité
de nos sociétés donc il faut être précis
quand on parle de ça et et si on veut
des politiques mieux ciblées je pense
qu'il faut être plus précis
la parole à Anne Catherine Loisier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
présent chers collègues mesdames
messieurs merci beaucoup donc pour tous
ces éclairages moi j'avais juste une
petite remarque en fait essentiellement
madame Marquet sur yat
la solidarité on la pratique puisque je
crois qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui à la
France livre de du gaz à l'Allemagne
donc je dans le cadre de convention
effectivement bilatérale moi je
m'interroge vraiment même si l'Europe
doit effectivement favoriser cette
solidarité mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'elle soit attentive à ne pas aller
trop loin dans ce qui pourrait être vécu
comme une espèce de Missou tutelle des
états enfin mon avis c'est un sujet très
délicat à une période où la perception
de l'Europe par nos citoyens est quand
même et quand même en juin alors en fait
moi j'avais surtout une question pour
revenir sur notre autonomie et notre
souveraineté et énergétique et sur les
plus vulnérables aussi il se trouve en
fait que beaucoup plus vulnérables se
chauffe au bois voilà et s'il y a bien
un point commun entre vous tous c'est
que personne n'a parlé de l'énergie bois
qui est quand même la première source de
chaleur en tout cas en France
et donc Madame marquez moi je voulais
savoir un peu comment comment vous
appréhendez les décisions les dernières
décisions
concernant concernant la révision de la
directive red qui qui conduirait à
exclure la biomasse ligneuse du champ de
la directive et donc les bûches et les
plaquettes qui aujourd'hui servent à
chauffer de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens particuliers et
collectivités et qui donc se trouverait
déclassé avec une fiscalité qui
exploserait donc je pense vraiment que
dans le contexte actuel il faut
peut-être qu'on essaie d'optimiser
les ressources dont on disposées pour
lesquelles on a une certaine
souveraineté
plutôt que de les renchérir merci
Jean-Yves Leconte
oui merci et merci pour vos éclairages
qui sont particulièrement
malheureusement inquiétants et je le
remets en travaillait sur la question de
la baisse de nos de nos émissions
carbone les optimistes peuvent se dire
finalement si on constate notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles c'est
cohérent avec nos objectifs de réduction
des effets de toutefois
tout ce qu'on peut faire alors qu'on
représente que 9% des émissions
mondiales c'est peut-être un exemple
or notre crise énergétique n'est pas un
exemple pour le monde donc quoi qu'on
peut faire sur le reste si on n'arrive
pas à résoudre cette crise énergétique
rapidement alors nous ne serons pas un
exemple sur nos objectifs exemplaires en
matière climatique la deuxième chose
c'est que
je ne sais pas si c'est bien ou pas
parce que dans la crise que nous avons
il faut regarder tout personne n'a
évoqué
les raisons qui expliquent qu'en 15 ans
les États-Unis sont sortis de leur
dépendance énergétique et est-ce que je
suis désolé de te poser la question et
je ne voudrais pas la réponse soit
positive mais je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus s'interdire de poser la
question est-ce que c'est un modèle
est-ce qu'on peut changer
la dépendance de la Russie avec ce que
fait actuellement la Commission
européenne vis-à-vis de l'Azerbaïdjan
finalement il y a aussi une question de
valeur qui a été un peu exposée par
Pierre Laurent tout à l'heure
la construction de finalement l'économie
énergétique de l'Union européenne depuis
depuis qu'elle existe enfin qu'elle
existe depuis très longtemps c'est la
concurrence alors quand on regarde
comment on s'achète le gaz et le gaz
russe était à des prix différents en
fonction des acheteurs et en fonction
des pays est-ce qu'il est pas temps de
se dire que sur un certain nombre
d'achats stratégiques en matière
énergétique il doit y avoir une
politique vraiment commune d'achat et
d'égalité pour qu'il y ait pas
finalement de
de distorsion ou du marché et ça revient
aussi ce que fait actuellement en
Allemagne en matière de de compensation
de l'amortissement tarifaire qu'elle est
en train de mettre en place
enfin il y a toujours moi je trouve un
impensé sur quand on parle d'énergie en
particulier d'électricité c'est les
réseaux de transport et le fait qu'on
considère que transport ben c'est le
transport donc en fait c'est pas la
production donc on regarde pas on peut
aussi faire des investissements dans le
transport en matière de
supraconductivité en matière de réseau
de transport aussi d'autres vecteurs
énergétiques comme en particulier
d'hydrogène et je voudrais avoir votre
avis sur cette espèce de que moi j'ai
l'impression de conseils c'est un petit
peu lubie française de se donner la
première ministre à évoquer hier
l'hydrogène nucléaire enfin je veux dire
quand on n'est pas capable de produire
l'électricité nucléaire comment est-ce
qu'on peut en plus se demander comment
on va faire de l'hydrogène nucléaire
donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce que
cette lubie engendre comme friction
entre la France et l'Allemagne en
particulier et comment est-ce qu'on peut
arriver à travailler aussi parce qu'il y
a des exemples qui sont en train de se
mettre en place d'importation
d'hydrogène qui proviennent de
Mauritanie et du sud de la Méditerranée
pour alimenter un certain nombre
d'astyrie qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire en
matière de de pour vraiment construire
ce réseau hydrogène et travailler avec
les pays du Sud où il y a un potentiel
solaire quand même un peu supérieur aux
autres
merci Jean-Claude
merci madame la Présidente
alors merci pour les pour les propos que
vous avez tenu jusqu'à aujourd'hui
jusqu'à maintenant à propos que je
partage finalement le constat qu'on peut
partager après les réponses que vous
apportez peut-être un peu sont un peu
difficile à entendre mais pourquoi pas
moi j'ai une question assez précise je
voudrais aborder la directive sur ces
énergies renouvelables qui est encore en
cours de négociation au niveau européen
et le traitement qui est réalisé pour la
petite hydroélectricité dans ce texte en
effet suite à l'adoption d'un amendement
qu'il devrait perdurer seul les
installations hydroélectriques avec une
capacité de production de plus de 10 MW
minimum ce qui correspond à la moyenne à
la grande hydro pour en rester dans le
champ des énergies renouvelables au
titre de cette directive ainsi pour
l'instauration de ce seuil la petite
hydroélectricité est sacrifiée et n'est
plus considérée comme une énergie
renouvelable sur ce sujet il est bien
sûr indispensable de respecter la
continuité écologique et les
réglementations en vigueur mais se
priver d'un levier de décarbonation est
incohérent à mon sens dans période
actuelle et face aux enjeux de
transition énergétique alors que
l'hydroélectricité est la grande absente
du projet de leur gouvernementale sur
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ce retrait
européen pourrait être préjudiciable
pour de nombreuses petites installations
ainsi je leur souhaité savoir si vous
aviez éventuellement des éléments sur le
traitement de l'hydroélectricité au
niveau européen est plus spécifiquement
du coup pour la petite hydro merci
très bien bien vous laisser peut-être
répondre les autres peut-être pas sur
toutes les questions mais chacun mais
peut-être madame marquez vous pouvez
vous avez été souvent voilà
[Rires]
interroger interroger interroger je l'ai
dit de façon amicale
ok j'essaye de un peu lié à les
différents questions que vous avez que
vous avez mentionné peut-être
plusieurs d'entre vous vous avez parlé
des révélations avec les pays tiers et
c'est ce que nous les offrons
comme
relation commerciale
étant donné que on est très dépendant de
du point d'un point de vue énergétique
et mais que eux aussi ils ont un
légitiment
des intérêts que nous devons tenir
compte
et là les sujets je crois qu'on a on a
adopté une communication amenée de cette
année sur nos relations internationales
énergétiques avec les pays tiers et je
crois que la Commission européenne a
proposé
un système innovatif je dirais
jusqu'à maintenant effectivement on a
acheté du gaz on achetait du pétrole de
cette attière de cet un producteur et on
s'arrêtait là plus ou moins
des fois il y avait quelques transferts
technologies ou coopération dans
d'autres dans d'autres champs mais en
général on avait des relations de
simplement d'achat
et pour beaucoup de ce pays
effectivement des fois ils ont senti
qu'on utilise certains façons parce que
des fois les prix du gaz qu'on a acheté
n'était pas très haut par exemple c'est
les cas de du gaz qu'on a acheté de
l'Algérie jusqu'à ça fait
très peu et c'est ce qui a créé aussi
par exemple l'intérieur de l'Algérie
beaucoup de mouvements internes des
politiciens des groupes politiques qui
disaient que bon ça y est c'est fini ce
sont nos ressources naturelles nous
devons mettre un prix conséquent pour
ceux qui c'est ce que nous vendons en
Europe et ailleurs
c'est ce que nous proposons maintenant
c'est effectivement de continuer à des
se diversifier comme ça pouvait pas être
d'une autre façon malheureusement on n'a
pas autant d'énergie renouvelable qu'on
voudrait ou nucléaire pour un pouvoir
remplacer le gaz qui nous consommons
aujourd'hui
donc on va falloir dans ces situations
de guerre changer notre fourniture du
gaz russe pas gas venant d'autres pays
mais c'est clair et je l'ai dit à la fin
de mon intervention notre objectif à
long terme c'est pas le gaz
le gaz pour nous c'est une technologie
transition qui doit nous aider à
équilibrer notre consommation avec notre
production de renouvelable
mais c'est ce que nous voulons c'est
avoir des rénovénables autant que
possible pour le pays qui le veulent
aussi les nucléaires et bien sûr nous
voulons regarder de plus en plus
l'hydrogène qu'on fasse des remplacer
remplacer les gaz dans les utilisations
qui ne peuvent pas être électrifiées par
exemple certains
manufactures industrielles ou certains
types de transport
donc notre message avec les pays tiers
dont on achète le gaz c'est de plus en
plus Nancy je dirais on leur dit
dans les relations qu'on a commencé à
voir avec eux depuis six mois les
discours est différent les discours et
de dire nous voulons bien sûr votre gaz
nous voulons acheter plus de gaz qu'on a
fait on faisait auparavant parce que
nous devons remplacer le gaz russe par
d'autres types de gaz
mais c'est pas là la fin de l'histoire
dans les futurs c'est ce que nous
voulons acheter des bouts c'est
électricité électricité rénovable et
c'est hydrogène rénovable
et donc quand on nous ouvrons ces
perspectives dans ce pays en disant on
veut de partenariat à très long terme
avec vous pas simplement
les temps que nous nous décarbonissons
mais nous voulons que vous développiez
aussi grâce à notre technologie et
l'aide de nos compagnies européennes
dans votre territoire les énergies
renouvelables suffisant pour créer
d'électricité et pour créer des
l'hydrogène nous croyons que c'est un
message beaucoup plus
intégré et beaucoup plus à long terme de
de c'est ce qu'on a eu jusqu'à
maintenant
on a commencé à établir des c'est ce
qu'on appelle des mémorandas avec
certains de ces pays et tous ceux
mémoranda qu'on a signé jusqu'à
maintenant ils s'incluent des chapitres
concernant l'hydrogène et l'énergie
renouvelable c'est par exemple les cas
des mémorandum qu'on a signé avec
l'Egypte et avec l'Israël même chose
avec la cerveillance
mais bien sûr on est conscient que
il faut pas simplement remplacer nos
dépendances successives par une
dépendance par exemple dans le futur de
l'hydrogène d'ailleurs
nous croyons que nous avons besoin de
développer tout d'abord les la
production d'hydrogène domestiques donc
à l'intérieur de l'Union européenne mais
même si on le fait dans des très gros
volumes et vraiment dans son objectif
sont immenses on parle de 10 millions de
tonnes de production de
hydrogène en Europe
ça sera pas suffisante pour remplir les
besoins qu'on aura dans les futures donc
on devra avoir au moins la même quantité
des importations d'hydrogène venant
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que on est
conscient qu'on va aller voir établir
des des partenariats stratégiques avec
nos voisins et des fois avec des voisins
très lointains parce que
l'hydrogène dans la forme de d'ammoniac
peut être transporté à très longue
distance pour pouvoir assurer la
décarbonisation des notions de série
deuxièmement sur la question de
[Musique]
la question de long terme court terme
donc un peu ce
point de vue qu'effectivement sur
lesquels je suis d'accord qu'on est très
souvent en train de essayer des chipoter
de mettre des petits patchs pour
continuer à marcher et mais n'est pas
prendre des décisions stratégiques qui
parfois sont dures
au moins depuis l'Union européenne
depuis la Commission européenne on est
un peu
la conscience derrière les États membres
en disant attention il faut prendre des
choix stratégiques il faut aller pour
les renouvelables il faut aller pour
l'efficacité énergétique c'est la seule
façon que nous avons de vraiment avoir
pas être indépendant complètement
énergétiquement mais avoir un peu plus
d'indépendance dans les futurs de ce
qu'on a mis aujourd'hui
et les problèmes c'est que mettre ça
vraiment impratique c'est difficile et a
besoin de beaucoup d'investissement pas
simplement public mais aussi privé
public la majorité des fonds qui
on était alloué en cet amende dans les
programmes next generation du groupe ils
vont aller à la transition énergétique
ou au changement climatique donc il y a
une grosse opportunité des financement
européen qui peuvent être utilisés pour
la production de l'hydrogène pour la
production de l'énergie renouvelable
pour la rénovation de ces édifices donc
il faut absolument profiter ça mais ça
sera pas suffisant il faut aussi
l'investissement privé pour cela
troisièmement sur la question de
vulnérable
je suis totalement d'accord qu'elle est
vulnérables sont des plus en plus
sont de plus en plus
vulnérables c'est un terme qui ont les
sociétés membres des définis les
consommateurs vulnérables donc chaque
état il y a quelques critères mais
chaque État établis qu'est-ce qui est
considère vulnérable
et nous croyons que les vulnérables
doivent être spécialement aider par les
pouvoirs publics mais c'est vrai que
avec les prix l'électricité du gaz que
nous avons actuellement
les difficultés sont en train d'être
soumis simplement pas simplement par les
vulnérables mais aussi par la population
moyenne en général
par les foyers par les petits et
moyennes entreprises c'est pour ça comme
je disais qu'on a changé aussi notre
cadre législatif afin de permettre cette
ambre temporairement pas simplement
aider
tous les foyers c'est ce qui n'est pas
et d'État mais aussi aider les
entreprises le petit et moyennes
entreprises effectivement pas les
grandes les grandes un corps considérés
comme et d'état donc il faudrait voir
s'il y a des raisons suffisantes pour
donner de l'aide
pour tout ce qui est grand consommateur
industriel les missures qu'on est en
train de prendre c'est plutôt des comme
j'ai dit plafonner les prix de gaz
essayez d'établir des nouvelles
délimiter les revenus de producteurs en
fromage d'électricité etc
[Musique]
et je crois que c'est important de ce
point de vue qu'on
défend tous un peu les règles de la
concurrence là c'est sûr parce que il
faut se rappeler et ça a été évoqué les
cas de l'Allemagne qui est pas tous les
États européens ont la même possibilité
financière d'aider leur compagnie donc
grâce à ce qui nous avons des règles de
la concurrence on peut au moins
s'assurer
que les effets sur la concurrence à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne sont
pas excessivement fauchés par des septs
publics
ils doivent penser ce qui n'est pas des
centres pour ce qui n'est pas des
entreprises il n'y a pas de problème
pour ceux qui sont des entreprises il y
a des règles de la concurrence que mes
collègues de la DG Concurrence la
direction générale des concurrence
doivent regarder et doivent autoriser
bien sûr il faut les autoriser
troisièmement sur la question de la
révision du
des la directive renouvelable
je ne connais pas les détails par
exemple de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans les négociations sur
l'hydroélectrique
ça je ne connais pas encore qu'est-ce
qui parce que je suis pas je suis plutôt
l'hydrogène je ne suis pas tellement
l'électricité renouvelable mais la
position de départ de la proposition de
la Commission pour la rémission de la
directive et bien sûr très positif par
rapport à l'hydroélectrique
et l'hydroélectrique
pour nous
pour nous pour nous la proposition tout
compte comme renouvelable
après les négociations ça peut mais pour
nous c'est renouvelable et pour les
biomasses qui ont parlé aussi de la
biomasse
on est aussi super
en faveur de
de la des renouvelables biomasse la
biomasse consiste et la source la plus
importante des renouvelables aujourd'hui
en Europe c'est absolument nécessaire on
pourra pas faire sans elle et d'ailleurs
ma commiseur qui vient d'un pays
Baltique où il y a des grosses la forêt
et c'est la plus intéressée et celle qui
a défendu le plus les la considération
de la biomasse comme renouvelable bien
sûr dans les discussions à l'intérieur
de à l'intérieur du Parlement européen
du Conseil il y a aussi certains autres
intérêts
des groupes qui considèrent que il y a
certains problèmes de durabilité
de la biomasse
dont il faut tenir compte donc ils ont
c'est un peu le jeu politique là qui
joue
nous faisons une proposition après
c'est vous les politiciens qui les idées
[Musique]
oui je voulais juste
compléter par rapport à la question de
modèle
US d'indépendance énergétique parce que
en fait il y a je pense que c'est un
lien aussi avec l'histoire de la
compétitivité donc quand on fait des
choix technologiques pour notre énergie
on fait un choix de quel est notre
niveau de compétitivité donc la France
et l'Allemagne ne sont pas
ils n'ont pas la même comme les utilité
en dépendant de prise de gaz et
indépendant des combien de centrales
nucléaires on a
à l'arrêt ou pas donc le choix
énergétique c'est un choix de
compétitivité qui a été déjà souligné
par la commission d'ailleurs
depuis des années et donc il y a aussi
c'est le choix de compétitivité il est
aussi un choix d'indépendance dans
l'essence l'électricité ne peut pas être
transportée à travers les océans sauf
l'Inter connexion et
interconnexion qui sont très coûteuses
comme celle qui a
sera indépendant et plus on aura besoin
des matériaux des métaux pour pouvoir
construire tous ces et donc c'est là où
il faut et là j'ai beaucoup travaillé
développement en Amérique latine et la
Chine a beaucoup d'expérience dans ces
sujets donc il fait des gens Adventures
avec des saintes avec des milliers dans
des pays en développement et il fait
toute la accompagnement donc il
effectivement il développe à la fois le
pays du Sud ont garantissant des
ressources pour son pays donc c'est une
et le chemin vers le renouvelable dans
le sens large c'est-à-dire batterie
batterie grande batterie hydrogène
changement d'où sage donc
électrification d'usage
plus de plus de transport en commun même
grandes lignes etc plus tout ça sera
produit ici en
créera et plus comme c'est des secteurs
avec plus de technologie plus de
diversification et nos partenaires nos
partenaires commerciaux en dehors de
l'Europe seront aussi auront plus de
retombées et plus intérêts pour
implémenter tous ces mêmes technologies
chez eux donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important par rapport à les boules
d'érables donc effectivement chacun
parmi nous a une idée de qui est les
burnales vulnérables d'ailleurs si vous
vous rappelez le rapport de chiec disait
que 10% des plus riches
aimaient 40% des cas ça fait de serre
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'il consomme 40% des salariés fossiles
donc si
bien évidemment que
et c'est pas les chiffres on peut pas
prendre les chiffres directement pour la
France mais si c'est le cas vous voyez
que on pourrait enlever on peut rester
épargner 40% des des
subsides
fossiles ok si on laissait libre au
marché chose les 10% les plus riches je
suis en train de faire un gros
un gros raccourci que j'espère vous me
permettez juste parce que c'est une
discussion informelle voilà
[Rires]
payer le vrai prix des choses et pas les
donner des subventions et même si on
veut les donner on veut les censité on
peut les donner des incitations pour
installer des panneaux dans leur maison
changer à des voitures électriques moins
polluantes plus petites etc
très rapidement parce que le retourne
peut-être deux trois remarques de ma
part
la première sur cette fameuse neutralité
technologique dont la France évidemment
que la France souhaite et que l'on sent
que dans un certain nombre d'État
membres à Bruxelles ça coince je crois
que là il y a un vrai sujet quand même
mais il faut pas oublier une chose c'est
que en France on a passé quand même 10
ans à pas savoir vraiment sur quel pied
danser c'est à dire on voulait plus
vraiment relancer le nucléaire vous
voulez plus vraiment avancer dans les
renouvelables donc finalement ce qui se
passe à Bruxelles refléter un peu ça et
à Bruxelles il se trouve que les
Allemands et les Autrichiens et ça tombe
d'autres eux avaient une vision très
claire du gaz russe pas cher en
complément des renouvelables et puis
ensuite on fait de l'hydrogène
au moins c'était clair donc ils ont été
très convaincants et entendu je crois
qu'une partie du du cabinet de Madame
vanderline reflète encore ça maintenant
le sujet c'est effectivement en France
on voit clair dans un certain nombre de
détails européens en Europe centrale on
voit très clair sur ce qu'on veut c'est
à dire du nucléaire pour sortir de
charbon et il faut que maintenant ça se
soit quand même pris en compte à
Bruxelles de façon une équivoque et là
je crois qu'il y a encore un tout petit
peu de chemin à faire
quitte à aller un peu de tordre le bras
d'un certain nombre de partenaires
maintenant nous dans notre relation
bilatérale avec l'Allemagne le sujet
c'est quand même de reconnaître que bon
les Allemands sont très plantés dans
leur affaire mais que par ricochet ça
les impacte sur nous que notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique là depuis
quelques mois dépend très largement de
l'Allemagne et donc de du relance du
charbon et du gaz en Allemagne et un
petit peu d'ailleurs de l'Espagne parce
qu'on tire aussi de l'électricité des
spines qui est produite avec des
centrales à gaz et d'ailleurs dans les
deux pays en Allemagne et en Espagne on
a produit beaucoup plus d'électricité au
gaz que l'année d'avant parce que il y a
le problème français il faut quand même
le dire et c'est un vrai problème donc
l'autre message pour les Allemands c'est
de leur dire mais effectivement en fait
le nucléaire en France il est il n'est
plus surpuissant il ne pourra plus tout
faire il faut qu'on rééquilibre très
fortement sur les énergies renouvelables
d'ailleurs on veut qu'il y ait des
investissements Allemands dans nos
grands projets d'éolien en mer etc parce
qu'on pourra pas tout faire nous même
et de la même façon ça voudra dire de
dire aux Allemands bah écoutez
maintenant on attend quand même aussi
des positions beaucoup plus neutres sur
un certain nombre de dossiers qui sont
absolument essentiels pour nous et quand
le président français dit et aux
Espagnols et aux Allemands le projet
Mika tout ce que vous voulez c'est
complètement absurde on veut même pas en
entendre parler on est choqué des deux
côtés et nous on s'isole complètement
et du coup les Italiens sortent du bon
en disant bah pas de problème nous on a
des infrastructures on peut même faire
un tube sous-marin à travers la
Méditerranée pour vous connecter etc et
regardez du côté de chez nous parce
qu'on est très pragmatique en Italie
voilà donc là il y a quand même il y a
quand même aussi une question de posture
où il faut aussi regarder ce qui se
passe chez nous pour pour comprendre un
peu comment ces dynamiques se jouent à
l'heure actuelle on est très isolé en
Europe en fait et quand vous allez à
Berlin et ben il faut 10 ben une partie
de l'accroissement de nos émissions
cette année c'est pour vous c'est pour
servir la France
je crois qu'il faut l'entendre alors
ensuite juste un mot sur nous ne sommes
plus un modèle pour le reste du monde je
suis absolument d'accord je crois c'est
extrêmement préoccupant parce que le
reste du monde nous regarde en disant ah
les Européens sont ceux qui sont les
rois de l'ambition de la déclaration ils
veulent l'un ils ont arrêté les énergies
fossiles avant tout le monde résultat
ils en ont plus ils sont dans un choc
économique etc bon c'est vrai qu'il y a
un vrai problème de modèle et l'autre
problème de modèle c'est que il nous
regarde et on n'a pas fait assez de NRD
ça donc en fait on est vulnérable des
deux côtés et sur les fossiles et sur
les énergies Rennes mais on a quand même
un certain nombre d'atouts à faire
valoir je crois que ce que disait ma
collègue Tatiana c'est extrêmement
important c'est-à-dire d'aller voir ces
pays en donnant une vision de long terme
et une vision vraiment intégrée on n'est
pas juste là pour prendre de l'hydrogène
on est là pour avec des capacités sur
les réseaux sur les énergies
renouvelables sur l'agriculture sur les
villes propres et durables etc mais
cette approche là il faut encore la
consolider il y a beaucoup de chemin à
faire je crois que c'est très
intéressant
initiative vous en avez peut-être rendu
de parler qui vise en fait aider à
fermer des centrales à charbon avant
leur durée de la fin de leur durée de
vie technique donc à financer cela à
accompagner cela et à développer des
systèmes alternatifs ça c'est une
opportunité énorme parce que
ça peut mobiliser nos entreprises ça
répond à des problématiques très
concrètes dans ces pays-là qui eux aussi
comprennent que garder un mix avec du
charbon ça va ralentir leur attractivité
pour les investissements etc ça crée de
la pollution donc ils veulent aussi se
sortir de cela et notre force dans le
monde de demain ça va être aussi de
montrer qu'en fait on est capable de
réaliser cette intégration de la
poursuivre des marchés la plupart des
pays de mon nom du monde qui vont devoir
développer des énergies renouvelables en
fait ne sont pas intégrés avec leurs
voisins et celle-là elle est à concept
intégration à la construire elle dégage
d'efficacité et là on est un modèle à
leur proposer et le dernier chose c'est
qu'on est des seuls ou parmi les seuls à
pouvoir mobiliser des capitaux beaucoup
moins cher que le marché et dans un
monde où en fait les taux d'intérêt etc
notre capacité à les présenter voilà des
offres de financement très intéressantes
pour un certain nombre de pays je crois
en émergent va va pouvoir faire la
différence mais
voilà là aussi je crois que la stratégie
extérieure du Green Deal elle est encore
à faire alors il y a une communication
externe enfin tout ça est quand même
très on va dire formel maintenant il
faut la traduire dans la réalité et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des vrais
opportunités à noyer d'autant plus qu'on
voit que ça tombe de pays dont on
pensait qu'ils étaient nos partenaires
le Sénégal l'Afrique du Sud etc et bien
évidemment reste extraordinairement
attiré par deux cargo de céréales et des
prouesses d'armes de vente d'armes
russes c'est quand même assez
préoccupant évidemment
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre moi je
me permets cher
je suis très intéressée évidemment et
vraiment merci beaucoup des apports et
des positions qui ont été les vôtres ce
matin qui sont tout à l'heure je l'ai
entendu inquiétante finalement parce que
je trouve qu'on a vraiment du retard à
l'allumage on a du retard à l'allumage
vous avez utilisé le mot de terre j'ai
versation pendant 10 ans je pense qu'on
est dans des terres et versations et
dans des modèles économiques différents
qu'il faut arriver à rapprocher en
Europe et je me doute que c'est pas un
sujet facile à faire c'est un sujet qui
va falloir faire et moi je suis très
préoccupé peut-être comme certains de
mes collègues par le temps
par le temps parce que tout je l'ai dit
hier en devant le gouvernement tous les
jours tous les matins on a des
entreprises qui nous disent mais
c'est pas dans deux ans ou dans trois
ans qu'on va disparaître c'est au 1er
janvier là et donc je suis très très
occupée vraiment par à la fois la
nécessité d'aller vite à la fois dans la
nécessité d'aller vite prendre des
dispositions qui sont des dispositions
qui sont
orthogonales par rapport à des objectifs
stratégiques c'est à dire le
conjoncturel qui va nous faire déployer
un plan de protection des entreprises
peut-être de l'ensemble des concitoyens
européens c'est de l'argent qu'on fasse
du c'est de l'eau dans du sable donc
c'est nécessaire mais mais ça construit
rien et en même temps la nécessité
d'avoir tes capitaux et des
investissements monstrueux pour changer
de stratégie et avoir une stratégie
européenne de l'énergie voilà c'est ce
timing là c'est cette cette difficulté
de calendrier
qui est très difficile et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure mais il est parti
monsieur Pellerin Carlin parler de des
collectivités territoriales vous
comprenez que les des collectivités
territoriales elles n'ont plus un seul
chiffre l'un et qu'elles ne savent même
pas comment elles vont clôturer leur
budget 2023 ils ne savent pas la date
comment 2023 les 2022 déjà ça va peine
elles vont elles vont aller puiser dans
leur ressources d'investissement
puisqu'il paraît qu'il y en a mais en
tout cas 2023 tous ceux qu'on rencontre
partout nous disons c'est pas faire
notre budget 2023 on sait pas donc voilà
on est dans cette dans cette urgence là
voilà qui est très très compliqué à
gérer pour tout le monde en tout cas
vraiment merci pour vos interventions en
plus il y a une autre volée qui s'ajoute
à ça que vous avez dit c'est que les
marchés réagissent aux politiques donc
si on voit que la politique elle est
plutôt souvent Sion fossiles pour passer
le cap etc on va avoir encore moins des
investissements sur les sources dont on
a besoin pour le moyen le moyen terme
c'est ça
ok je m'associe au propos de Sophie pour
vous remercier bien sûr
moi il y a deux choses qui m'ont qui
m'ont interpellé ce matin c'est tout
d'abord vous nous avez dit Monsieur el
mazega nous sommes dans un modèle
martial donc on
est dans une économie de guerre
mais avec notre philosophie européenne
et de l'Union sans vouloir y être donc
ça c'est un vrai paradoxe à gérer de la
part de nos populations parce que
notamment en France mais je suis sûr
dans d'autres pays de l'Union européenne
on n'a pas encore compris qu'il y a 3000
km de chez nous il y avait un conflit
et je crois que ce paradoxe est aussi
provoque aussi la peine que nous avons à
faire passer les messages notamment sur
la sobriété bien sûr sur
l'inflation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et ses raisons et puis sur
le coup de l'énergie donc là on a
vraiment aussi un travail et un travail
politique à faire à l'échelle européenne
je pense à l'échelle de la commission
j'en suis certain pour donner peut-être
une autre image de la commission
aujourd'hui
qui soit plus
une commission
en soutien en soutien des en soutien des
états et en soutien des populations
parce que sinon aujourd'hui et vous le
voyez et je ne suis pas alarmiste on a
une configuration qui est quand même
assez dramatique
effondrement de la monnaie
on peut commencer à parler
d'effondrement parce que ça baisse vite
quand même effondrement de la monnaie
inflation considérable et c'est en lien
bien sûr
problème d'économie d'énergie et puis
des vulnérables qui augmentent et dont
on ne sait pas encore quelle est la
définition quoi est-ce que ce sont des
gens qui peuvent se chauffer est-ce que
ce sont des gens qui peuvent se nourrir
ou tout simplement des gens qui qui vont
être à la rue donc moi je suis vraiment
enfin dans un j'ai pas j'ai pas un
caractère pessimiste mais je suis dans
dans l'esprit d'inquiétude bien sûr et
je rejoins vraiment votre propos en
disant attention on ne veut pas de la
guerre bien sûr mais préparons-nous à
cette à cet effet on